purposes so that that was a great
commitment on his part
and in that was about 1.2 million
dollars for electric
school buses
a few years back
we tried to issue an rfp uh covet hit
and other things intervened and it just
didn't work out so well and then des
decided to focus primarily on putting
out the
rfp
for the charging on the travel
corridors which is a prime
recommendation that came out of the
electric vehicle infrastructure
commission that we had for a couple of
years
so now it's time to come back to this
using this funding that we have from the
volkswagen settlement for
the electric school bus pilot program
but in a way it's serendipity because
some things have changed
the buses themselves have matured and
then also this vehicle vehicle-to-grid
technology has become something that
really can be seen as a way to monetize
the size of the batteries in these
vehicles and make some money potentially
for
school school districts by doing that
and i'll explain that in a little bit
later
on the other thing that's happened is
that we're getting more money for
electric vehicle
charging infrastructure there's 17
million dollars in
the
the transportation bill that's coming to
the state for electric vehicle charging
infrastructure
and then also there's a two and a half
to five billion dollar grant program
that is in the infrastructure bill and
we'll be able to apply
uh for those funds uh and that can
include uh particularly money designated
for
electric buses so that puts us in a good
shape now to use the funding that we
have for an electric
school bus pilot program
conversations on the bill that we know
that des has the money it is going to
move forward so the point of this bill
is to do it right
right do it efficiently to take
advantage of the vehicle to grid
technology and i i think you know truly
set us up to save a lot of money for
local
school districts as they transition
their fleet to
electric school buses
right now across the country and you can
go online i sent you a
link to some presentations um the
jessica wilcox of you know new hampshire
des clean energy uh and others gave
about electric school bus programs um
recently over in vermont but doesn't
you'll find a lot of information out
there
about them they're about 1 500 on on
order or in
service
many
communities including boston have
committed to transitioning their fleets
eventually
entirely to electric
school buses
blue bird
just had its largest order and
anticipated saving a lot of money for
the school district that
that ordered them there are pilot
programs in other
other states as well very similar to
this massachusetts has a couple
communities in their pilot program that
have their
their buses um so we have a lot we can
we can learn from that so let me turn to
the bill mr chairman um
there is a variety of definitions here
as as one would need for
a program with electric school bus pilot
program i'll point to lines 11 uh
starting line 11 on the
first page here
this notion of incremental cost because
here's here's the uh kind of true
here's the way we're going to use this
uh volkswagen settlement
and other funding um currently
a bus
conventionally fueled diesel bus might
cost
i know a couple hundred thousand dollars
you know you see a lot of different
prices depending on the size and and so
forth uh whereas an electric
um school bus might be a couple hundred
thousand dollars more i mean that cost
differential is coming down but um like
a bluebird 84-seater it might be that
kind of incremental cost
difference and that's the cost that the
bill
will cover
with the
grant funding
then the other thing the bill does is
this definitions of the vehicle to grid
and interconnection facilities
because now the bus is paid for
the electric utility can come in do the
make ready work to get the charging in
there
and then
through the mouse that will be developed
with the
school districts
that the capacity to use these batteries
as storage can be monetized
so they're large batteries
they sit most of the
most of the evening in the lot or in a
lot of the summer
so they can be charged up
when the electricity is cheap
and then when peak comes at the uh you
know the end of the day
that power can go back into the grid
and so it can save the utilities from
having to
pay expensive for expensive power during
peak demand
and
that's something that could be monetized
so that the school district can receive
some some payment for that i think we're
going to hear more about vehicle-to-grid
from new hampshire
electric electric co-op which is kind of
pioneering in the states some of this
technology but this is this is what
other school districts are doing
i'll say you know maryland baltimore
county uh has just started 150 million
dollars of these buses and this vehicle
to grid technology is at the at the
center of why that order is going
through and how they figure they're
going to save um quite a bit of money
so
after the definitions on page two you'll
see
what we do the department of
environmental services
can take that volkswagen mitigation
trust fund and other federal funding
that comes in through those grant
programs to create and administer
the program i'll put out an rfp as
you'll
see and then on line eight there here's
the amount of funding that's available
to offset the intermittent cost so this
is what the grant
um will do is it'll cover that integra
incremental
cost
um and what this will do for schools
it's it's not just that i think that you
know these these are great vehicles
they're going to save money but also
let's talk about children's health um
that diesel
fine particulate matter
particles we know are one of the you
know
very very deleterious particularly on
children's lungs in terms of asthma and
other damaging diseases
and studies show that the
level of those fumes is about twice as
high inside the bus
as outside the bus
so this is and there's no idling either
you know you see the line of school
buses outside the school idling and that
that electric school buses don't sit
there and idle so that is an ancillary
benefit for for sure in terms of um
children's help so the qualifying uh
program pilot um
will allow uh proposals by the group
that you
see here um i have an amendment for you
um it was pointed out we we need to
change line 13
so that
line a
instead of re
qualities because that's the definition
of let new hampshire electric co-op it's
not investor owned it's a co-op
um it doesn't go through the puc so
that change in definition would mean
that they could participate in the
program as well as eversource and and
unitil liberty the others who have
expressed their interest in it is as
well
um
so then uh here's the um
what the mou
would need to do
and i think it's important starting on
20 because here's the agreement that
will empower
the school districts to monetize this
and to to make some money so
the local electric utility to access and
utilize the energy stored in the
batteries um at times when such action
is necessary to meet current power
demand or when utilized the energy and
the stored batteries can lower the cost
of supplying power to customers
um provided that the school district
determines they're not needed at those
hours at which the power might uh be be
drawn
um
then you'll see in line 26 uh as is done
in other states and you know eversource
this is kind of the usual boilerplate um
after review from the department of
energy um the cost to utility for the
make ready transmission or distribution
to a facility
that's important because the make radio
costs uh some money to bring the the
power lines in there
for the charging
um charging stations and
if we don't do the cost recovery there
it means we have much less funding to
spend on the buses themselves
and that's a good investment for the
future of course too because as the
fleet slowly transitions to more and
more electric you've got the charging
infrastructure there so you've made that
base investment already
and then i just another thing that came
out very importantly
in the senate
hearing on this is starting on lines 31.
you go out on
online and you're going to find concerns
about
well
you know what happens with these buses
in the winter can they keep warm
or not and
does it reduce the battery range
to the point that that creates a problem
will the students be kept warm enough
and so that's why
we put the lines in here that not only
does it have to comply with the
recommendations the national
transportation safety board as all
school buses have to do
but also provide for adequate interior
heat for winter
operations now i've got an electric car
and it's clear when it you know on a
standard 20 below zero the battery range
goes down
one way that the electric vehicle
manufacturers are dealing with this is
that instead of using a heating element
as in a conventional vehicle
that heats up draws a lot of juice to
heat the car they're moving to heat
pumps
and heat pumps draw a lot less
electricity
but the point here the mou you'd have to
you know ensure
with the
supplier that you're buying the
vehicles from and i'm actually the
bluebird cummings which is the largest
diesel
manufacturer in the country for diesel
engines is committed to going
all-electric for its manufacturing and
it is it is providing the electric um
engines for these these buses so they
it's coming as a great company if you
know and they and uh
mac and peterbilt and the other
companies that make heavy diesel engines
are all going all electric so they're
you know the technology is going to
going to be good here if an average
school bus maybe maybe does 120 miles a
day
um the range here is 100 you know can be
150 180 miles on a charge uh of course
you can top off the charge during the
day
a lot of you know and you would
determine which school bus is going out
when and and so on so that's how that
gets dealt with i thought it was
important to point that out because you
know that's a concern you'll find that
in the internet and so on um
and then the rest of the bill
kind of um talks about data and analysis
importantly again costs and benefits and
costs of the pallet program is it
working right you know because the money
actually being saved are the buses
functioning the way they're supposed to
do that's why you do pilot programs
right
um and so they'll be reporting as you'll
see on page three
um the costs and benefits uh auto
language here um senator birdsall was
particularly
interested in here and you know how is
the vehicle to grid technology working
out you'll see that on line eight on
page
three
and uh then
you know this the get a successful grant
for that
epa funding it'll be a new rfp so that
we give new people an opportunity to
compete for whatever funding we get um
beyond what is authorized in the first
rfp
so mr chairman
there it is
i'd be glad to take any questions before
i
head off to another bill introduction
thank you senator any questions from the
committee representative talersky thank
you thank you senator for taking my
question thanks for being here um this
is really exciting
um possibility that uh we can consider i
am curious is there any idea of how many
buses will actually fit into this
initial pilot program or how many
districts will be able to participate
well you know we have in hand the 1.1 or
1.2 million
um
and uh
if the incremental cost is a couple
hundred thousand
so maybe we can do six yeah um but
you know that other money that other
that that two and a half to five billion
dollars is is going to flow they're
writing their rules and regulations on
it now in washington at some point
they'll be
what you can re request so um
my my feeling is that you know that's a
good start and although the pilot
program you know we'll see how do these
work yeah what kind of mu now there
there are several school districts that
are quite interested
in this um i don't know if you have any
communication from over here from from
today but uh the house
nashua
uh manchester i think we're going to
hear from some communities up north in
the electric new hampshire electric
co-op that they're interested in doing
this so i think we'll have people lining
up
for this rfp
thank
you and thanks for your question
representative o'hara thank you mr
chairman thank you senator for taking my
question i know you're really busy today
i don't know i don't mean i'm sorry i
shouldn't even mention it i'm happy to
answer questions um so the cost for the
department of energy additional
employees is that covered under the vw
trust and federal grants as well
um
i think it's there's a line in here i
don't know if i can find it right away
uh that says that
the des costs
yeah you see online three
page two
for the purposes of funding and
administering this program
and um becky owers
here
from des you can talk about that there's
going to be maintenance involved in in
some of these buses and i'm assuming the
school districts would be responsible
for that or maybe that's covered
under
this initial
pilot program funding but i'm also
curious about the
storage
using the batteries for storage during
that time who pays who pays for that
electricity to uh to go into those
storage batteries
and how is that
apportioned if for some reason the
school department wants to use it during
that time period that it's full versus
just using it for
for storage how is how does that system
yeah thanks for the thanks for your
question and you know it's just it's a
it's really fascinating how you know
we're moving into the ear of uh just you
know changing distribute energy
distribution right and these these kind
of local arrangements we you know we
have community
aggregation now
um we have net metering we have all
kinds of ways and you know schools are
putting solar on their roofs and
and so on and so that's the point of the
mou
because that's where you figure that out
that you know um it's it's gonna be a
meter and the meter reads both ways
power coming in power coming out and the
idea is you're putting cheap power in
and then selling more expensive power
back to the
back to the grid so it's a question of
metering
and i would think that if the school
decides if they're in a community
aggregation situation which you know we
passed that last year it's getting
implemented a bunch of communities have
signed up for it
that i would think this would be a
suitable
qualifier under under that so that you
get to use the power that's in community
aggregation locally and
and you can save the power for your
community
it's a pilot program i mean these are
these are you know great questions and
this whole landscape is kind of changing
about vehicle to grid and we're learning
from a lot of other places so the mou
and the pilot program and that's why the
reporting is saying how is that working
how is it working financially um and
again i from what i've seen from other
communities
is that this can be a
an income stream
now for the maintenance thing the way
the mou's have also been set up is to
say that
the you know the winner of the rfp
has to provide the training
on the vehicle to grid the electrical
things and any necessary training on the
vehicle maintenance um but let us note
that
one of the reasons you know my best move
that's the california i just saw a
recent report they're figuring they're
gonna save like three hundred thousand
dollars a year
not just with fuel we'll get to look at
the price of diesel today right versus
the price the price of what you'd get
for you know per gallon equivalent of
the energy you're putting in i'll tell
you in my car you know gas is what i saw
like 395 410 on the way over here i'm
paying about a dollar or 10 or dollar 20
of a gallon gas equivalent when i charge
up so if you're charging charging up the
cheap you're gonna you're saving money
there but the maintenance costs right no
there's no fluids
okay there's no there's no um muffler
system um the
there's there's
i mean i don't know what it takes in one
of
these um
one of these uh engines and there then
there is in a conventionally fueled
vehicle so the maintenance cost is one
big kind of cost savings area of this
kind of vehicle
yep follow-up
um thank you i um
i'm wondering too whether
the areas that you've talked about that
have these programs in place has any
gone full cycle meaning that they've had
to
replace
batteries or or engines or anything like
that
or are we still in that first
initial phase when you're using
the
equipment that comes with it thanks for
your question i'm not aware of any
in north america um
because you know these buses last for a
long time
i mean i've been reading lately they've
seen some of these battery packs my last
500 000 miles you know um you know the
epa said you got to put a radio on so
i've said 100 000 miles but the
experience is that they're lasting for a
lot
longer now i know that these buses have
been running
overseas for a long time
10 15 years so i there may be there
but here um
you know the the 1500 vehicles on order
are in service so it's relatively new um
lion which is one of the largest
manufacturers of diesel engines canadian
company and buses
they've been deploying them up in canada
for a few years
but it's
it's relatively new still so we'll see
pilot program thank you we'll see
any other questions
cnn thank you very much thank you so
much and i'll be seeing you a little bit
later won't i see you thanks again and
and if any other questions come up um in
subsequent testimony i'd be glad to
answer or anybody offline can please
please be in touch thanks again thank
you chair recognizes griffin roberge
from new hampshire energy department
not taking a position
uh thank you mr chairman uh members of
the committee for the record griffin
roberge from the new hampshire
department of energy um the department
is neutral on standard waters 417.
um
as amended by the senate the bill does
as senator water mentioned creates an
electric school bus pilot program to be
administered by the department of
environmental services
however there are a few references to
the department of energy in the bill to
determine if a local electric utility
can access and utilize the energy stored
on these bus batteries
to allow utility to recover reasonably
incurred costs in the pilot program
and require selected pilot applicants to
provide information data and analysis
that the department requires
the department wanted to raise a few
technical concerns with the bill
specifically page 2
lines
22 i'm sorry i should say lines 21-22
it indicates that the department must
review and approve efforts
from the local elections
utility to access and utilize the energy
stored in electric school bus batteries
quote at times when such action is
necessary to meet current power demand
the department is unsure how it would
measure and quantify at what times it
would be suitable to meet current power
demand
i think holistically how and when energy
use energy storage or electric school
bus batteries for that matter utility
may following review by the department
recover costs for make-ready
transmission distribution to a facility
and other costs reasonably incurred in
support of the pilot program um the
language doesn't clearly specify who the
utility is recovering
the costs from i think we would all
agree it might be from
a utility's customers but that's just
not abundantly clear
additionally the department
per the language of the bill would only
have review authority it would not have
approval authority
over the recovery of those costs
additionally the public utilities
commission maybe not the department may
be the more suitable body to fully
review and approve the recovery of those
costs as the puc regularly does that
through an adjudicative process and open
dockets and through a public process
so those are just a few technical
concerns that the department wanted to
raise on the bill
that really concludes my testimony and
uh happy to take any questions that the
committee might have
thank you sir
were these issues brought up when this
bill was still in the senate i have to
look back you have to forgive me me and
another staffer split responsibility
between the senate and the house i don't
believe
those concerns were specifically
i'm looking at the hearing report
specifically brought up in the senate
but i would like the opportunity to just
double check with that staffer and make
sure
thank you any questions from the
committee
cnn thank you very much thank you
uh
chair recognizes michael lacata from
nhec
in support of the bill
sorry about that is that better
good morning my name is michael akata
representing new hampshire electric
co-op
we serve 85 000 members with electric
distribution service in 118 communities
across new hampshire
as the chair said in support of the bill
very much appreciate senator waters hard
report of that
this is an area that actually the co-op
has done quite a bit of work in
vehicle-to-grid charging
electric school buses we've had a number
of conversations with school districts
across our service territory as well as
bus distributors and vehicle-to-grid
vendors
this is an exciting area where
the batteries went idle could be used to
export back to the grid which could be a
benefit to
all of our members by reducing uh
transmission and capacity charges that
the co-op uh has to pay in order to
provide service to our members so
i'll be brief because i know senator
waters covered quite a bit of this
ground and you have a full slate
but in support of the bill um
heard some of the concerns by
representative hill
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um can you comment on the
the amount of infrastructure and or the
condition of the infrastructure
necessary to
to do more than just the pilot program
but to do
a fleet sure it it really is site
specific um
so
every utility when
um
additional development or a solar
project or if this was sort of
large-scale charging
needs to do a review it's called an
interconnection study to determine
whether the local infrastructure can
accommodate that load and if not what
upgrades new transformers need to be
installed in order to accommodate it so
it really is site-specific
and so
that would be a study that would be done
um these would be significant
charges obviously school bus is a large
vehicle a fleet of vehicles would be
significant chargers
the chargers themselves
the sort of fast chargers level three
and above
are you know significant pieces of
infrastructure
just ballpark in the range of you know
in excess of a hundred thousand dollars
but of course
you know there are different payment
structures to uh
to install those
um
is it safe to say
right now
if with this pilot program we don't have
that infrastructure or would there be
needing to
to expand the capacity now
uh it would really depend on the the
specific capacity of a line
what the bill contemplates in the pilot
program contemplates is
funding to be made available to
support the purchase of the charging the
chargers themselves the vehicle-to-grid
chargers themselves
as well as some of those additional
expenses so um there is capacity you
know obviously we're interconnecting
people every day um and interconnecting
solar facilities every day uh so it
really is site specific and utility
specific
but i don't want to leave the impression
that we have a constrained system
because many areas can accommodate
without grid infrastructure i'd
recommend getting in touch with the
prime sponsor
as well
if this passes and is adopted if this
amendment is adopted it'll still be
returning for concurrence so there will
be other opportunities just want to let
you know that we'll be acting on it
today excellent thank you very much
thank you
jay recognizes
kelly buchanan
clean energy new hampshire
in support of the bill
okay thank you mr chair and members of
the committee i appreciate your time
this morning for the record my name is
kelly buchanan and i'm the director of
legislative and regulatory affairs at
clean energy new hampshire
we are in support of senate bill 417
and i should mention that as part of our
organization we founded and managed
drive electric new hampshire which is a
coalition of ev advocates
who work primarily through education and
outreach means to
increase the adoption of evs in the
granite state as well as to
increase the availability of the
charging infrastructure necessary for
these vehicles
so this issue is close to our mission
and we are excited to support the bill
because it is appropriately timed and
exceptionally well designed
there are several school districts in
new hampshire already very interested in
this to name two in particular
that are actively exploring that would
include the oyster
river cooperative school district as
well as the national regional planning
commission
both of those entities are exploring
electric school buses as we speak
it's important to mention that the
funding for this this pilot is already
available to us and here in new
hampshire there's a lot of funding
coming down from the federal level that
would support this as well
and it's important to note that ev's
school buses provide an enormous cost
savings opportunity in the form of
lower maintenance costs as well as less
cost on the fuel side
they also provide an enormous air
quality benefit to children
the amount of diesel emissions that
exist within school buses today is
detrimental and especially to asthma
rates so switching to evs would improve
that that air quality element
and as senator waters mentioned there
there has been some concerns expressed
on the senate side about these vehicles
keeping warm
from experience i can say that they they
do just fine
so
we are also in support of the
vehicle-to-grid technology that could
result as a result of this pilot program
this is an excellent way to further
study how ev school buses could be both
an asset to getting children to school
as well as to the grid and to provide
some support in times of high demand to
the electric grid
having these school buses charge up
overnight typically on a level two
charger so a charger that moves a little
more slowly and is a little more
affordable
could provide a benefit later in the day
when we reach a peak demand event and
that battery could be discharged to the
grid to reduce rates for customers in
general in a specific utilities
district so
with that i would be glad to take any
questions
and thank you for your time this morning
thank you any questions from the
committee
representative thompson
um
i live
in far northern new hampshire
and
our school buses up there
they get down to 40 below zero
we have temperatures at 40 below zero as
a matter of fact up until recently the
the only time that the colebrook school
district has ever
canceled school was because it was 42
below and the buses wouldn't start
what are we going to
what is our expectation for electric
buses in extreme conditions
sure and i think it's like any other
vehicle right you know it is a little
the efficiency does go down in extreme
temperatures especially in the cold but
those are all things that you can
account for in your operation and i
would expect and
really have no other expectation that
these buses would be comfortable and
operational
in the
the normal route of business you know 40
below is quite extreme and i hope kids
get to stay home from school in that
sort of situation
but i would expect that they would
operate entirely normally in
cold conditions
okay thank you very much
thank you
any other questions from the committee
representative oregon
and we are running late
what is the range of these electric
school buses
it's a good question um and it's not one
i have at the top of my mind
unfortunately
um
perhaps rebecca ohler from the
department of environmental services
could answer that for you okay thanks
thank you
seeing no other questions thank you very
much thank you
last person i have signed up to speak
rebecca olaf from new hampshire
department of environmental services
who is not taking a position on the bill
good morning thank you very much for the
record rebecca ohler department of
environmental services and i'm actively
googling what the range is
the department has not taken a position
on this bill but obviously we are very
happy to be
included in the in the proposal to
operate this program we are the agency
that's been
tasked with distributing the vw
mitigation trust
that was passed over to des when the
former office of strategic initiatives
became was merged with the new
department of energy
we actually explored an electric school
bus proposal um probably five years ago
and it was just simply too stupid too
soon the the school districts weren't
quite ready to be considering that the
technology was not as advanced as it is
now the number of vehicles being offered
was was um you know there's basically
one choice and one choice only
we now have
multiple bus companies that are
developing and and actively selling
electric buses across the country so
this is definitely a a much better time
to be
exploring this
um
there were a couple of questions that
were floated to to senator waters and i
thought i might just um offer
my take on those and uh one the first
one was about what is the maintenance of
these buses and i think senator waters
did address this to the extent that the
maintenance is actually far less on an
electric vehicle any type of electric
vehicle than its conventional
counterpart because there are no there
there are no oil changes there's no fuel
system to maintain
um you know it's an electric motor there
is no engine
uh there's also less wear and tear on
brakes because the electric motor is
serves to to
slow the the vehicle much of the time
the the brakes actually engage fairly
infrequently because the electric motor
runs in reverse to slow the vehicle down
in in the process of doing that it's
recharging its battery bank so while
it's driving and doing stop and go the
way school buses do it it actually
partially recharges itself it's one of
the reasons why
electric is such a great solution for
things like transit buses and and school
buses because of the and garbage trucks
for that matter because they're
constantly starting and stopping and so
they recapture a lot of energy as they
stop
um
there was there was also a question
about whether there's any projects old
enough to require the replacement of the
of the electric
um
motor or the batteries and i'm not
aware of any the
folks in massachusetts
have some of the earliest electric bus
projects in this part of the country
those buses are now probably
eight or nine years old and
i haven't gotten recent data from them
but
um at last conversation they were not
having any issues with having to to do
wholesale replacement of batteries
um
so
uh
that was that part and then
um
there was also a question about some of
the costs to upgrade the uh
the electric infrastructure and
while i can't share details because it's
an open request for proposals right now
we are
currently evaluating proposals under the
vw mitigation trust
for
installation of electric charging
infrastructure around the state and as
was noted it really is dependent on the
location we're seeing some areas where
it's going to cost less than ten
thousand dollars to do the connection of
a high-powered charger to the grid and
other places where the estimates are
over two hundred thousand dollars so
it's really completely dependent on on
where the where the project is located
and i think that that would probably be
a significant consideration when
deciding
where to do a pilot project for this i
think it would be
likely to be done in an area that's
ready for it
thank you very much any questions from
the committee
representative o'hara
just a quick question um is the
infrastructure
the infrastructure costs that you see
regional like is it more northern area
needs
more infrastructure costs for this type
of program than the south or
no um it's just really dependent on
whether you're on the west side of town
or the east side of town so it doesn't
really matter which which town you're in
i will note that
some
potentially easy fixes to language are
are have been floated in the back of the
room here and we may be able to i'm i'm
reluctant to propose them right now uh
coming from des but i will share
no you can have the conversation with
the others that are going to do the same
thing so okay yeah
so thank you any other questions from
the committee
seeing done thank you very much thank
you
anybody else wish to speak on senate
bill 417
seeing that i'm going to close the
public hearing
give us a minute to reset next bill up
will be
senate bill 442.
just those
is
uh
cheers
it's
yes
um
okay
i'm gonna open up the public hearing on
senate bill 442. the chair recognizes
senator birdsell prime sponsor
442.
sorry
i was just in the middle of a
conversation let me get my wits back
about me i'm pretty sure that's not
the verdict i wasn't even looking up
excuse me
i thought okay
senator senator waters
no
no i'm right yeah oh it is me okay no
it's not we're we're on senator bill
442 so the chair recognizes senator
birdsale please prime sponsor
i know you're an anxious senator
this is relative to the suspension of
vehicle registrations as a result of
evading tool collection systems
thank you
mr chair thank you committee for
hearing 4-2
my name is regina bartzel state senator
for district 19 which encompasses the
towns of
derry hampstead and windham
and i am the prime sponsor of 442. this
was brought to me by the department of
transportation they had they have had
some issue major issues with people
running the tolls not paying the tolls
and you'll hear some of the information
from d.o.t
but this bill would allow the director
of the department of motor vehicles to
suspend an owner's vehicle registration
until the any unpaid tolls and
administrative fees are paid and there's
quite a lengthy lengthy way for them to
um
to
try and get that money back before they
suspend
the registration
the senate amended it to because there
was some concern from
the auto dealers
so we did amend it to say that because
there were there are some some concerns
of
individuals who have transferred their
vehicles over to family members
and continue to rack up those unpaid
tolls so the senate did amend it to
not allow
family members who live in the same
household family members or those who
live in the same household to have the
vehicle transferred over
you'll hear a little bit of information
about that when dmv
gets up as well as d.o.t so with that
i'll try and answer any questions but i
think the dot has a really good
explanation of what's going on with the
tolls
thank you senator any questions from the
committee
seeing them thank you very much thank
you
i have two people from the new hampshire
department of transportation uh john
cochran and kathleen mckay lee hans i
mean okay hanson
i was going to ask if you can come up
together and save some time that'd be
great uh both in support of the bill at
this point
[Music]
good morning chairman walsh and members
of the house transportation committee um
kathy mulcahy hamson i'm the legislative
liaison for the department of
transportation and their senior hearings
examiner and with me this morning is mr
john corcoran who's the administrator
for the bureau of turnpikes who oversees
um the toll collection in the e-z pass
system um i'd like to thank senator
birdsell for working on this bill with
us and sponsoring
senate bill 442. the purpose of the bill
is to close loopholes
in the current law on
essentially toll evaders
we were looking for two changes
to the current law the turnpike system
is maintained and operated with
toll revenue
we need to maintain a system that's fair
that has credibility so when a user
chooses to use the turnpike system they
know they have to pay the toll and if
they choose not to pay the toll or can't
pay the toll then they have to use an
alternative toll-free road
the purpose of
the pending bill senate bill 442
is for better toll collection
enforcement in dealing with those who
choose to use the turnpike system but
not pay the tolls
so that
i think to
understand why we're looking for these
changes i'd like to explain a little
about how the toll collection works
pay at the time of use you pay with a
transponder with an easy pass account or
you pay cash in
at the time of use
if you don't pay at the time of use
the user has the option of paying online
within seven days of the transaction
just the toll no additional fee
so just the toll within seven days
if the individual doesn't pay within
seven days then we begin an invoicing
process and we'd send an first invoice
requesting payment of the toll plus a
dollar fee and that's payable in 30 days
if the individual doesn't pay in 30 days
we send a second notice requesting
payment of the toll and a dollar 50 fee
again 30 days to pay
so the user's getting a lot of notices
if they don't pay the second notice when
30 days it escalates to a violation and
they receive a third notice a violation
notice requesting payment of the toll
plus a 25 dollar fee
if an individual incurs 10 or more
violations
they are sent to dmv hold
before that happens when they become
eligible for d and b hold
the department reaches out through to
the individual through the department of
turnpikes
and tries to resolve the issue you you
have too many violations we're going to
send you to dmv holds
if you don't clear these you won't be
able to register your vehicle so a lot
of people will clear them up at that
point some won't
so the person goes to dmv hold what that
means is the department of
transportation sends the information
over to our partners at dmv under the
department of safety
dmv sends a letter out to the individual
a notice that says you have 30 days to
clear these e-pass violations
if you don't your privileges to renew
your registration will be denied
that is when their birth month usually
rolls around and they're due for
registration they can't register
the department seeking to change that
part of the law from the renewal to an
actual suspension so that when dmv sends
their notice out it will say you have 30
days to
clear the easy pass violations or your
registration is suspended it's more
immediate
as a senior hearings examiner i have
some top violators who come to me and
ask that their
fees be reviewed and you're talking some
people can owe 500 700 i've had
people who owe a thousand dollars in
tolls alone
um and they they they asked me well why
did you let my total get so high
we don't have a way to keep them off the
road
um they they can keep driving on the
turnpike system and and we don't have a
way to stop that
if their registration is suspended
suspended and they're
not legally able to operate their
vehicle that's a more effective method
to stop it so that's the first um
request we're changing where you'll see
up in the
the bill on line
eight it
goes from it's crossing out the word
renewal privileges so that instead of in
their birth month when they go to renew
their registration
it's that their
registration
is suspended
so they can't operate within 30 days of
the dmv notice so that's the first
change we're requesting
the second change we're requesting um
is um to address people who have become
very creative in circumventing the dmv
hold process
um
they had um gone before and gotten a new
plate um and letting the old plate
expire we closed that loophole they're
no longer able to get a new plate
now we have people who transfer
ownership a husband transfers ownership
to his wife or his fiancee
so that's the
basis for the second change we're asking
that
the transfer of ownership on that
vehicle that incurred the violations
would be prohibited
in terms of transferring to a family
member or someone who lives at the same
address per dmv records
and i want to
let the committee know that in
discussing this this morning with dmv
they took a closer look at this and
have an issue in terms of
prohibiting transfer among family
members but i will let them address that
because that has to do with their
dmv systems
but those are the two
changes that we were looking at to
tighten up this system keep it credible
and make people pay the tolls if they
choose to use the turnpike system
so i thank you for your time
and if there's any questions we'd be
happy to answer
thank you very much
any questions from the committee
representative telersky
thank you for taking my question very
quickly can you give us an idea of the
number of um
people we're talking about in the course
of a year that you're dealing with in
these extreme situations that hit that
point
we're dealing with approximately 50 000
to 48 000 plates
every year
that are going to be going to hold
now some of those are these duplicate
two where
it's the same plate that goes into hole
because they just keep repeating
repeating
but overall
i mean this past
year in fiscal year 21 we dealt with
38 33
000 plates and getting payments and
stuff
quick follow-up
follow-up and do you have an idea of the
amount of
money we're talking about then that's in
arrears that
i i don't have that with me it's a lot
thank you
represent thompson
um
it took 10 minutes to explain this
process how long does it take to enact
it
and what are the costs involved in doing
that
to go through all the steps that you
described to us to
get someone to
pony up the money
approximately four months
approximately four months from the date
they violate through the tolls until we
put them in dmv hold
follow up
um
it just seems to me like
you give them way too many breaks that
this this legislation should be cut
much shorter
um to save the department time
and money
to the state taxpayers
i wonder if you recoup all the money
that you
spend in time
by collecting these tolls
yes we do recruit i mean i'll say we're
in the positive from the money that we
spend on our staff the
our
vendors cubic who sends out all these
invoices and the postage we pay
we are in a positive from collecting
each year okay thank you
representative horrigan
thank you very much mr chair um
what happens and this doesn't seem to be
directly addressed by the new language
the bill if the
car is in fact owned by a
well it could be a trust many people
have their cars owned by a
revocable trust although those could i
suppose that that could be construed as
individual or if they
if it's owned by a corporation it seems
like they could actually even if we
passed this bill they could still
transfer it to an llc or a trust and
then
um run out the clock a little bit more
that way thanks
thank you for the question
representative oregon we do have um in
fact there's one that comes to mind
a certain corporation that has taken the
company vehicles and they've created
i think three or four llc's in the past
couple years and they transfer the
vehicles amongst the corporations so
they can avoid paying the tolls but they
are a legal entity and it is um this law
would apply to them as it does to an
individual
thanks thanks for the questions
cnn thank you very much thank you very
much
the chair recognizes director john
marasco new hampshire department of
motor vehicles
who is not taking a position on the bill
at this point
good morning chairman walsh good morning
to the committee thank you i have uh
euro chief jeff oberdenk with me this
morning who oversees registrations and
um just like to
start off by thanking senator birdsell
for introducing this bill and for the
work that dodot has has done on it as
well
for many that i haven't met here on the
committee my name is john marasco i'm
the new division of motor vehicles
director i'm happy to be in the position
and working with so many great people
i just completed my first month so some
of the bills that are coming before you
i'm still getting up to speed on this
one included and i just stepped out to
make a few additional phone calls on it
we actually i know it's informational
testimony i would say we support the
bill at this point and the reason i say
that is um there's there's just one
section in there uh the family portion
of it where it says family member for
our systems at the dmv that might be a
little difficult to configure i just
spoke with our
doit contractor who advised me that as
far as legal address goes
we can tether that to last name and if
that last name is the last name of that
relevant family member then we're going
to be able to configure the system to uh
to capture that
so that's what we can do if it's a
family member that lives in a different
jurisdiction
in a different house that that would be
difficult for us to uh to ascertain but
as far as the portion of the bill that
talks about address we can we can
conform to that and um
and probably conform to that relatively
quickly so
i think it's a good bill we want to help
uh
dot where we can with these easy pass
violations um certainly there's a lot of
money there i would just caution the
committee the one thing that we maybe
cannot commit to at this point is the
family member that overreaching
wording that part of the bill but as far
as
address and last name tethered to the
address
dmv we could conform to that
questions from the committee
representative o'hara thank you mr
chairman and just um a quick question
along the family member line
would it be possible to do a sworn
affidavit davis for the buyer i'm just
worried about buyer someone buying a
vehicle from someone that's been running
tolls and they now have a car that they
can't register
but
i still want to be able to stop the
loophole from the family members
right
it's a good point i guess that would
require further conversation i'm not
sure on the affidavit offhand
think i think what we have here is a
step in the right direction based on
what dodot testified to the chance to
actually identify the address where the
violator is and anybody else that lives
at that address who may or may not be a
family member but lives at the address
to start curtailing the uh the behavior
that way to it's a good step in the
right direction
but i agree with you representative at
least it doesn't open up the scope
beyond that it's really the address that
we're focused on
for the questions from the committee
representative telersky this is very
quick it might actually be for you mr
chair i'm having i'm you just raised a
question um
is this preventing someone with these
violations from transferring ownership
in a private sale to someone who's not a
family member does it prevent sale of
the vehicle
no no it's just the transfer okay thank
you i want to clarify good question
further questions
seeing none i'll just be i just wanted
to be clear did
because i was just brought brought to my
attention a possible issue a few minutes
ago before we started the hearing are
you saying now the department after you
making a few more phone calls is
comfortable with the language is
currently in the bill we are sir we're
comfortable with the language with
regards to the address and family
members residing at that address the
only part i would say that
might be
something for conversation in the bill
is the just family member in general we
can't do a sweeping family member check
across the board but as long as it's
tethered to that address our contractors
can configure to that okay thank you
thank you sir um
thank you very much thank you
that's the last uh person i've signed up
is there anybody else wishing to speak
on senate bill 442
seeing that i'm going to close the
public hearing
uh give us just a moment we're going to
go right into senate bill 447.
i'm going to open up the public hearing
on senate bill 447 establishing the
electric vehicle and infrastructure fund
chair recognizes the prime sponsor
senator watters good morning again thank
you mr chairman members of the committee
senator david waters district 4
introducing senate bill 447 which
establishes an electric vehicle
an infrastructure fund
and
you know as you know we have received 17
million dollars from the federal
government for electric vehicle
infrastructure
and
it is quite likely we'll be receiving
well i'd say we would have a good chance
at receiving more from the two and a
half to five billion dollar grant
program that is set up
for this purpose as well so i had um
pretty extensive conversations with the
commissioner
and uh with bill cass and others about
wouldn't it be convenient and help us to
have a dedic a fund that was set up to
receive these and potentially
other monies
and that'll do that'll do a few things
for us um it will
mean that
there is a fund
that has a purpose
for expenditures that is outlined by
the legislative legislature it also as
you notice on lines um
15 to 16 suggested by senator birdsall
wants to make sure that as funds go out
the legislature has a look through
probably joint physical
um at what the purpose of those those
funds are
and then um if you look down to what
these things can be what that can be
used for the abc's here starting online
23.
these were written to match what
governor sununu
specified
in the acceptance of the volkswagen fund
so these these general buckets here
are ones that through the electric
vehicle infrastructure
commission and its report and um
through
um work with then oh
then uh
was it before his department of energy
oh i something anyways working working
with those folks and some of the same
folks the department of energy these
these uh in particular these seem to be
categories that the the governor
suggested and um
so
it was good to have these priorities
here uh and um this is what the funds
are receiving are probably meant for as
well so we want to make sure that we
finish building out the fast charge
system now that's identifies the highest
need for the state that's where
volkswagen funding on the current rfp
that is out and
proposals that have come in for that are
being reviewed now and we pretty soon i
hope we'll be hearing about who's been
selected to get that work going but the
money from the volkswagen fund isn't
going to do it all and that's why this
funding coming in from the um
the interest the infrastructure bill is
going to be important to help
work on that and then also
other transportation corridors besides
the interstates and 101 and and 16 so
some of the secondary highways pick up
the north country to make sure that they
get some infrastructure
up there
and then secondly i
wanted to make sure that
this vehicle infrastructure could be on
commercial property in new hampshire
downtowns are crying out for it
campgrounds at exits
shopping deposited exits as well so
that's a priority that was also
identified through the infrastructure
commission
and then
in c
state agencies and again that's a bucket
that the governor identified through the
volkswagen funds and it's good to have
that here as as well
now i want to note that this bill does
not tie
the
commissioner's hands in terms the
commissioner needs to have flexibility
in uh getting funding out and deciding
okay we've done enough of this now that
you know we ought to put a little more
into that or if they write a grant and
get a grant funded that will specify
certain areas of emphasis as well
but what it also does though is it
explicitly
says on page two
that we can contract with private
entities and this is something that was
learned through the rfpu process through
des and elsewhere there are companies
out there as you know who do this work
and they do it well
and um so we're not going to rely on dod
personnel to develop the expertise or
you know to have staffing that can do
that so you've been able to
bring in private contractors which again
the commissioner can do that but it's
good to specify it um here
as as well
and then uh if additional funds come in
on lines 2018 to 20 yeah so new new rfps
um let everybody be have a chance to to
to compete um for that as well and then
finally import and importantly starting
lines 21 that we're going to get a we're
going to reporting on you know how the
funding is doing
uh what what the needs are and what
additional funds have have come in so
mr chairman i think this would be useful
and um it's also some sense that having
this in place will
help us in applying for competitive
grant funds because we'll have a
dedicated fund that has some purposes
outlined for it and that can help give
us a leg up as we're applying for those
some federal and other funds as well
thank you mr chairman god to take any
questions
thank you senator any questions from the
committee representative good morning
good morning thank you mr chairman thank
you senator for taking my question i
just want to get clarity but you
mentioned you know we're getting 17
million from the feds and then you
mentioned you know the infrastructure
bill
are those two different
things are they one and the same
thanks for your question um so
there is a an amount as a portion to the
states and on various forms we've got 17
million for that
there's also 2.5 to 5 billion dollars in
there
and it has that variable range because
it's one of those ones where well if you
don't use it all in this then you can
use it on that but that is also in the
bill
and that's identified for these kinds of
purposes plus for electric uh buses um
so it's a it's a big pot of money and uh
states will be able to apply
for that funding
um so that's that's they're both in the
same bill but that's the distinction
further questions from the committee
seeing thank you very much thank you
chair recognizes rebecca ohler
department of environmental services
thank you mr chairman um i was just
noting that i am here and available to
answer any questions should there be any
all right thank you
uh next up kelly buchanan
clean energy new hampshire in support of
the bill looking for two minutes
a real two minutes
yeah hard act to follow senator waters
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee again for the record kelly
buchanan with clean energy new hampshire
i did share some written testimony with
you today so i will be very brief clean
energy new hampshire is in support of
senate bill 447
it is a prudent step to prepare for the
amount of federal funding that we are
receiving in the state and will help new
hampshire retain its competitive edge in
this market space
we are especially glad to see that in
terms of siding of any ev infrastructure
for charging that the appropriate
stakeholders are being brought to the
table
including
des the new hampshire transportation
council
new hampshire department of
transportation as well as drive electric
new hampshire
and this collection of folks will really
do a good job in citing all of that
appropriately
and with the right input
the only other thing i'll mention is
that setting up this fund for
acquisition in particular of evs will be
helpful in the very tight
vehicle market that we've been
experiencing it is challenging for new
hampshire to get evs
partly because of our current policy as
compared to other states and so anything
that we can do in that realm to help
assist new hampshire
have access to the ev market is
excellent and much appreciated in terms
of
accessing this technology so with that i
would be glad to take any questions
thank you any questions from the
committee
representative fenton hi thank you for
taking my question can you elaborate on
the policies that kind of restrict us
from getting evs
sure so some other states in
the us have policies that
make them more competitive in terms of
getting evs to dealerships new hampshire
does not have those and so typically
that's referred to as a zev mandate
because we don't have that in the state
a lot of folks currently go down to
massachusetts to get evs and other
states that have more availability in
terms of their stock and i know it's
hard to get a vehicle in general right
now
but anything we can do in terms of
setting up a process for
funding in new hampshire that would make
this easier would be helpful to the
state
further questions
see england thank you very much
this last card i have is there anybody
else here that wishes to speak to
senator 447
seeing that i'm gonna close the public
hearing
uh give us a minute to reset next step
will be senate bill 308.
hmm
okay being 914. we're starting it caught
back up
i'm going to open up the public hearing
on senate bill 308 relative to driver's
licenses for certain visa holders
uh chair recognizes senator waters the
prime sponsor welcome again
thank you mr chairman uh senator david
waters district four introducing senate
bill 308 relative to driver's license
for certain visa holders um this bill
was brought forward by
to me by by the farm bureau because of
issues that had arisen
under this program for
agricultural
businesses in the state that take
advantage of the h2a workers these
agricultural workers who come in
seasonally and uh have sometimes
long-term relationships with the farms
at which they they work and because we
didn't have in statute this kind of
reciprocity of what permits that we were
recognizing the situation arose that
somebody who might be driving you know
working at a farm in maine or in
vermont if they come and work for a farm
in new hampshire um that
they could you know they're driving farm
equipment on the farm or more locally
that they that the farmer could get in
trouble
about that because we didn't have this
recognition and potentially they could
be investigated or
the workers might have difficulty just
performing the work that they've been
hired to do so it puts it in statute um
that we recognize uh these uh licenses
or
permits from another another
jurisdiction
or has a permit from a jurisdiction
outside the united states and then 18
years lawfully present
present for less than a year
and has an international driver permit
if their license issued from a
jurisdiction outside the united states
is not written in english
so um fairly simple it brings us into
conformity with other states are doing
and make sure that
agriculture workers
and their employers in new hampshire
we'll be able to employ these folks
they've had for for many years working
for them i know that we have um
individuals here from the from the farm
bureau and uh division
of motor vehicles and um you know this
i think we answered a lot of questions
did an amendment that answered those
questions uh
in the senate and so here it is mr
chairman thank you
thank you senator any questions from the
committee representative gorski thank
you mr chairman and thank you senator
for taking my question
in the bill you mentioned you know
issued by another u.s juris u.s
jurisdiction can you elaborate more what
do you mean by another u.s jurisdiction
well thank you there's some folks behind
us but um
uh we do have
you know
you know i think of various united
states jurisdictions plus other states
so but i'll let them
i'll let rob johnson and the
commissioner talk about that
any other questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
next
next up chair recognizes stephen wood
representing himself in support of the
bill
good morning good morning thank you very
much um i'm stephen wood i own and
operate uh poverty lane orchards in
lebanon in plainfield as i have done for
my entire life
um and for the last 30 years or so we
have relied on a handful of gentlemen
from jamaica to do most of the
fundamental work or a lot of the
fundamental work at the farm
some of them have driver's licenses we
have always thought it was legal for
them with
a driver's license from another country
current driver's license
to drive in the state of new hampshire
in the same way that i can drive in
another jurisdiction with my new
hampshire license
this year um we were surprised by a u.s
department of labor inspection
in which we are the the initial fine was
for um
for having uh uh unlicensed
drivers
driving our crew around well the the man
who drives our crew around not only has
a current
jamaican license for a very long time
he's had a current international license
we need this bill please folks this i
mean
most of us thought this was already the
law
um but this is an exposure that
it's it's
unfair of us would be unfair of me to
put this exposure on our gentleman
and i don't think we should be exposed
to this either it is amusing that
poverty lane the lebanon police stations
on poverty lane
the police just waved to these guys
and when when when this same gentleman
i'm talking about uh he hit a deer in
plainfield that jumped out in front of
him
and the policeman called me up to make
sure that i didn't think it was the
man's fault
so there are some people in enforcement
who may not exactly know
that this is not the law now but i
implore you to make it the law thank you
very much
thank you sir would you take any
questions
representative horrigan actually i just
wanted to acknowledge that for a number
of years i've i now represent durham for
a number of years have been 198 poverty
lane and um so
everything you say about where the
police station is and the jamaican echo
echo figures was true then too back in
the uh
back from like 1996 to 2001 when i lived
in lebanon so
yeah so it's good to see you then
thank you for the question
representative oregon
representative
thank you mr chair
thank you mr wood for taking my question
um
as part of your business operations um
you're you you try to use the same
workers year after year after year
and the reason for that as i understand
it is that they have skill sets that are
really important that help you bring in
a more effective crop is that a true
statement it is true it's true most of
my colleagues as well i mean we try to
keep
we try to keep the same workers this is
the one place where we have no
authority about this
the the the the government ultimately
our government determines together with
the jamaican government determines
whether we actually get the people we
ask for but we have had the good luck
touchwood uh since 1992 of
we've we've got the people we we've
requested and we've had very
low turnover the
some of these people have worked for us
for 30 years um they're starting to die
they're getting old so yes and we
absolutely rely on them they they are
skilled long-term valuable employees
that are not replaceable
by by somebody anybody else it would be
a whole nother training process
um
and
that's you know we we feel we feel a
responsibility to
these workers
does that answer your question sir
it does thank you
representative hill
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um can you tell me a
little bit about who issued the
violation and and
where did the fine go and
yes i can
we
apple growers dread the era
occasional
cruise missile
audit by the u.s department of labor
and unlike
most audits
we have all
seen for years that
those inspectors are looking to bust us
for something
um and in fact representative sykes
question
what they're doing is looking to punish
us for taking jobs away from worthy
americans and giving them to offshore
workers which whether it's we may find
that ludicrous and even offensive but it
doesn't really matter so it was it was a
u.s department of labor inspection
that
uh was announced two days before it came
um we opened all of our books they had
access to all of our vehicles and all of
our buildings and they have the right to
interview the crew without anyone
present
um and uh
fortunately i wasn't there my wife was
there i think our fines might have been
a little higher if i'd been there
but
but uh uh
and the money went to the u.s department
of labor
and where they're from and get wet i
have no idea sir
do you want to follow up vote
um but
the the violation was a new hampshire
law correct
the violation was the observation that
that our
the laws of my state of new hampshire
did not allow a driver
a a a a temporary
alien driver
to drive on the on their own license but
that it that it required
that these people get new hampshire
driver's licenses which would be pretty
tough because they're not new hampshire
residents um
anyway that's yes it was a new hampshire
statute apparently
or the absence of one the absence of a
new hampshire law and and
is there any uh restriction if you if
they were driving
on farm property
and there's no restriction
there's no distinction made for
locally versus
no anywhere
i mean
we don't worry about driver's licenses
when we're driving
tractors on farm property we worry only
about competence
but once we go out on the public
highways whether they're
local state or federal
roads um
we
we understand that you're required to
have a license to drive on those roads
but again we have always understood
that a a a valid foreign driver's
license written in beautifully clear
english current
was was sufficient
thank you sir
any further questions
cnn thank you very much thank you thank
you good people
uh next up
robert johnson from the new hampshire
farm bureau in support of the bill
looking for four to five minutes but if
you could shorten that up a little bit
it would be appreciated okay mr chef
thank you for the record rob johnson
representing the new hampshire farm
bureau as a federation's policy director
we
we asked
this bill to be introduced after the
incident with with mr wood last fall and
we approached senator waters as we were
at the house deadline it closed and and
uh he had he had served on a study
committee that looked at the licensure
of non-citizen drivers that on recent
history what i wanted to do mr chairs is
give you a little brief on the what the
h2a program is
uh it's it's a federal program
administered by the u.s department of
labor homeland security and the state
department so these workers are vetted
by three agencies
it started in 1952 as an h2 program in
in 1986 which is named towards h2a
it allows agricultural workers who lack
excuse me agriculture employers who lack
available domestic workers to bring
foreign workers to the to the u.s to
perform and it's for seasonal work
that's tied to a certain time frame
of year an event or pattern or temporary
work lasting less than a year
and it includes primarily as planting
cultivating and harvesting of crops
ag employers they must post the job
outlining the terms and conditions of
employment
they have to advertise locally
and the employers pay the cost for
travel of the employees to the to the
united states and in their housing while
they're here
and also they pay their workers comp
and they must they have to follow a play
at minimum it's what is referred to as
an uh adverse effect wage rate
and it varies by state in in new
hampshire and in in this region it's now
1566 an hour
there are nationwide we're talking over
300 000 h2a workers that are certified
uh that were in in 2021.
um and that that's a huge jump back in
2013 it was about a hundred thousand
in new hampshire we're only talking
about my best guess is in the range of
200 to 250 workers
on about 40 farms the the largest being
right now
we have a couple farms that are in the
uh
40 plus worker range
and as mr woods said
it it uh
it not only provides
our farms with with we're farm workers
but with professional workers
the incident that mr wood experienced
again but i want to stress that it was
an audit it wasn't where the the
employee was out driving it was it was a
paper audit and it's from our
knowledge it's the second farm in the
states that's been cited and again it
was because they were not following as
the question was asked it was state law
and and we're getting just simply asking
for reciprocity here
and um
i'll i'll i'll finish up with saying i
mean it is in order for the
um to to to get a
if they don't have if we don't have this
reciprocity then our employers then have
to take the workers and the only place
that does it in state is at the concord
uh dmv and it's a it's a burden uh to
you know spend a day doing that i'll
i'll leave it at that mr chairman thank
you for your time and attention i i do
have letters that i will provide the
committee uh from uh uh of growers one
of them is here if there are any
particular questions
thank you very much
are there any questions from the
committee
seeing none all good thank you thank you
yeah can we get
uh
chair recognizes director morasco
from the new hampshire department of
motor vehicles
thank you chairman walsh members of the
committee and uh we have with us bureau
chief jeff oberdenk as well
um
as i stated earlier i had the
opportunity within the last couple of
weeks to review this bill and speak with
uh with jeff about the merits of it
first and foremost through the testimony
that we've heard
we want to make sure that we're doing
everything we can for the farming
community within the state of new
hampshire and
i know that some of the issues have been
with coming to concord the dmv a full
day
jeff and i have talked about some
different opportunities there to uh
either in newport to cut down on the
travel time or other opportunities maybe
to even go to some of the locations um
depending on the the number of workers
that are there so we're we're open to
that anything we can do to assist
a few things that have uh that have been
highlighted um
263 39a
which already establishes parameters for
international students at colleges and
universities and the fact that
you know upon 60 days of residency in
new hampshire you have to get a new
hampshire driver's license
the same thing for guest workers
so this bill appears to
carve out from an industry standard um a
little different scenario for for one
industry versus um another industry and
so that that would just be one thing
that that we would highlight the other
the other thing that we notice in the
bill is when you talk about driver's
licenses from other countries
reciprocity issues and we don't have
reciprocity with very many countries so
what are the standards for that person
having a driver's license from a
different country and then driving on
the roads here in new hampshire for an
indefinite period of time
beyond the 60 days because they're
working in a particular industry
and so i think
what we would like to do is work with
the the farming industry here we want to
see it thrive we certainly don't want to
be an obstacle to any of the uh the work
that's going on here but that being said
those are just some things that we would
want to bring to the committee's
attention and we'll take any questions
and certainly would be interested in the
sidebar with the gentlemen that are here
today
representative
thank you thank you for taking my
question can you just give us a little
more information about
if the international it was testimony
that the uh worker had an international
driver's license does that actually
count for anything here in new hampshire
thank you for the question
representative the international driver
permit is simply in an interpretation of
the current license that you hold and as
a matter of fact they're offered by aaa
it's not a licensing entity there is no
standard set forth we have a very
uh
i would say strict and regimented driver
licensing process throughout the united
states and canada and that's why we have
that reciprocal agreement with canada
but the international license is just an
interpretation of the card you hold in
your hand and that be something that you
would do before you take a vacation or
travel somewhere
thank you representative
um
gentlemen thank you for taking my
question i just want to be clear about
this though
is it not true that
you can only get an international
driver's license from the country from
which you come from in other words if
one of
poverty lane workers came here they
could could not get an international
driver's license from aaa here in the
u.s they would have to do that in their
own country that's my understanding
correct and not all countries and a
follow-up please
and not all countries
have programs
as like the aaa where an international
driver's license could be obtained
that's correct thank you
further questions
representative hill
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
is there
any opportunity to um
create a driving permit rather than a
license um for that period of time that
that known period of time that they've
signed up for this
and and whether it would be able to be
issued for the purpose of their their
work rather than a um
you know
the weekend trips places is that is that
even possible within our current
structure that already exists that's
what we do today so the length of your
visa determines the length of your
license
so if you're a permanent resident card
holder you would get the standard
five-year license because those are
typically good for 10 years or greater
if you're hearing a temporary work or
student visa would be for the term that
you're going to be in school or the term
that you're going to be employed by a
particular company so in this instance
if you were to be employed for the
growing season that would be the length
of the license that we would give you
and by the way we do that today already
quick follow-up follow-up so what does
this do that that that we don't
currently have
this would take our driver licensing
process out of the system you wouldn't
test here we wouldn't maintain your
driving record
we wouldn't be paying attention to
necessarily what you're doing it would
fall back on that home country or that
jurisdiction and i think to what the
director was pointing to is if we don't
have a reciprocal agreement i heard
jamaica used earlier if there were
infractions that happened on that
international license we have no way of
reporting that back to your home country
with this bill
if we maintain your driving record
because we license you we have a way to
track and maintain your driving record
for purposes of maybe at some point the
points get too high and we have to take
that license
maybe it counts towards insurance
ratings or those things but when you go
to this where there is no reporting
method back to those countries we don't
have that tool set to manage that record
any other questions
representative
thank you mr chairman
in that particular instance would these
farm workers need to apply and get a
driver's license every single year that
they return to work
they have to go through the application
process absolutely
the testing process would be something
that would be done initially and for
somebody that's coming here every year
we wouldn't have to do the test every
year
they would just have to fill out another
application and pay the fees or whatever
is involved correct
any other questions
representative
does the does the doe a dol or anyone
ever issue
when when people are approved to come
here for agricultural purposes do they
ever issue driving permits or anything
like that we are the only authority to
issue driver licenses here in the state
insane
yeah and i i guess just a different
angle of looking at it i mean obviously
in new hampshire we we consider driving
a privilege
and if you
violate any of the laws you can lose
that privilege
and lose your new hampshire driver's
license if this were to become law
how would you be able to or what would
you be
removing from somebody who broke the law
with an uh say out of
united states license
that's a great question without having a
reciprocal agreement there is nothing
that we could do
okay thank you
any other questions
seeing and thank you again both um
that's the last person i have signed up
to speak
anybody else wish to speak on senate
bill 308
seeing that i'm going to close the
public hearing
a couple of minutes and we'll be going
into senate bill 389.
um
okay we'll open up the public hearing on
senate bill 389
defining mobile service garages and
relative to state vehicle inspections
chair recognizes the prime sponsor
senator waters
thank mr chairman senator david waters
district four to introduce senate bill
defining mobile service garages and
relative to vehicle inspections this
might be a little deja vu for folks um
this version of this bill was before you
before and then as they say you got
covertized right so you know kobet came
and uh this
this uh had come through the senate and
it you know kind of happened to what
happened to a lot of bills
and so what the bill basically does is
that it
provides the
definitions and the parameters so that
the mobile service garage can do state
vehicle inspections
now for that purpose um the other
language is here we're going to hear i
hope you'll call peter bragdon next
about the garage and get out there to
take a look at one on the state house
state house plaza but what these would
be done is be brought in under contract
with a private employer for the
convenience of their employees so they
can get this inspection work and maybe
other work done in their car at the at
the place of place of work so that's the
convenience involved but um if it's
going to be authorized then we had to
make darn sure
in the definitions and in the other
parts of the language that this really
did function the way any other garage
would function and would have the
inspections would have the internet
capabilities for
the reporting of information on um you
know exhaust fumes and the other things
you have to report when you're doing a
state estate inspection um and that
basically is recognizing that we need a
level playing field that if this is
going to be mobile rather than a
stationary garage you need to make sure
can perform these functions
um so you'll see that's why all the
definitions here you've got to be able
to lift the vehicle
you've got to be able to take care of
any hazardous wastes
that might be involved in a garage
operation
function gps tracking advice so that the
inspectors if they want to do us
inspection the
folks at motor vehicles know where they
are and do their surprise
inspection if they want to do that the
internet connectivity have to make sure
they have that so that the continuous
data can be reported as it as is
required to be on certain kinds of
tests performed on the
on the engine and then is large enough
as you'll see out there
to
have a capacity to handle vehicles um
appropriately or work an appropriately
wide work area um again these are some
the statutory language kind of matches
what we have for other for regular
garages as well and is going to have
insurance
and is registered as a business has even
though this is mobile that there will be
an actual
office that's staffed so that again
dmv and others can know where to go to
an office and if there are documents and
records that have to be
looked at as as well
so then
you know given those definitions and you
see the bold here the existing language
about inspections being authorized
except as provided in paragraph 12 um so
it means okay these kinds of facilities
as defined up above can do this uh
inspection
work and this is um how you do it and
these are the fees and that stuff is no
different from what we do
already
and then into procedures and rules
around this um the decision was that the
the
the director would be the person who
would make sure that these kind of rules
uh and the methods of in
inspection
um these aren't going to be driving
around and poaching inspections from
other folks it's going to be under
contract with uh with an employer and on
that employer's
premises and
then
the obd testing
ordinances should be displayed as they
are displayed in a regular garage
mr chairman i'll say one issue has come
up here about the definition of mobile
service garage you'll see in lines three
to
five and then continuing
uh there and and the question is raised
by the the auto dealers was that well
what's really mobile i mean if this
thing is going to be sitting there for
six months to 12 months it's not really
a mobile
garage anymore it's a permanent garage
and uh and that's a that's a good point
so i think that we're gonna have some
discussion about perhaps an amendment
there that says you know maybe for a
certain number of continuous calendar
days um and i think that that would
provide some reassurance
uh
to motor vehicles and others that we're
not you know just trying to create a new
garage and it's going to be there
forever that this has really meant that
an employer can bring it in a large a
large employer can bring this in for the
convenience of their employees or
otherwise might have to have time off
for work or deal with daycare or
whatever to get their uh state
inspection done so i will stop with that
mr chairman we've got to take any
questions but i do recommend that you
call um mr bragdon
next because uh he represents the
the businesses and can tell you a lot of
the technical details thank you
thank you any questions from the
committee representative oregon
um yes
well i'm thinking back to my days with a
large employer in dover which was
measured progress which is now have some
other name having been acquired but
um they had
they had like a large number of people
on their campus as many uh
many operations do who are either
working for temp agencies or for
contractors and um
this looks like this bill is written and
this isn't the kind of thing that
particular employer would have wanted to
offer its workers i don't think but um
would only be able to offer that
particular inspection service to people
who are direct employees of the uh of
the company
thank you for your question and yes
that's that's the idea yeah it has to be
the you know contract with an employer
uh you know the facility is just like
you know just like a regular garage but
the contract with the employer would
specify that it's on the player's
premises for that
yeah that empowers employees so
thank you all right thanks
further questions
excuse me representative fenton thank
you senator waters i have a question on
page two about
the employers so if i'm a business of
one could i hire this
mobile station to come what's stopping
this mobile station from going to
quote businesses of one non-stop instead
of these large employers like you're
talking about
well thanks for your thanks for your
question um
i'm not sure anything the language
would prevent that but i will just
would
note the economics of this you're going
to hear from the business folks
and it's hard for me to imagine that it
would be a good business plan
to set this thing up and you know go see
it you'll see you got to set it up um
it's staffed and if you're going to do
one car for i don't know how many
dollars it is and then you're going to
have to drive to another employer
and drive to another
i'm not really sure that's something
that one of these vehicles would do but
um
that's that's my sense of it
any other questions from the committee
representative thompson
um
on
page 1 line 12 it says the
vehicle needs to have a minimum overall
width of 12 feet
in my business
if we have to haul something that's 12
feet wide we have to have over over with
permits
and
commercial licenses but i don't see any
of that in the bill
thanks for your question so if you go
out there and take a look what it does
is that when it arrives at a site it's a
you know regular van
the sides
fold down
and at the level of the lift floor
and then a canopy goes up
and then curtains come down so it's
fully enclosed
but you got your width
that way and then when it's folded up
it's just you know like a van going down
the road
yeah yeah thank you similar to a camper
with a slider yeah
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you very much
uh next up
peter bragdon and rick
mackley i think
from tcsa nh in support of the bill
okay
uh great thank you mr chairman members
of the committee for the record my name
is peter bragdon
representing
tcs nh llc
and to be honest i don't know what tcs
stands for rick mcclay is here with me
as well who is the principal of tcsnh
and he can probably i assume the nh is
new hampshire but the rest i don't know
here to present information on senate
bill 389 which has to do as senator
waters said with mobile service garages
and just a little bit of background this
idea started as an idea from an mba
student
at the tuck school of business at
dartmouth college back in around 2015 or
so
of an ability to
perform uh maintenance on vehicles um
passenger vehicles uh within an enclosed
area that was a little more portable
the economics of it however and this
goes to the question that representative
fenton raised
these are very expensive capital
investments to put one of these together
and the economics don't make sense if
you're going to move it around do one
vehicle then move it somewhere else and
do another vehicle
it doesn't make a lot of sense but where
it does make a lot of sense is if you
bring it to a large employer that has a
lot of people
at one place at one time and then can
schedule the vehicle services for those
people as you see at the bottom of the
handout
a number of large new hampshire
companies have used or currently use
this including dartmouth's on their
hypertherm
harvard pilgrim healthcare has used it
large employers when i was in the state
senate the largest employer in my
district was one of the largest in the
states that being fidelity
with several hundred
employed many hundreds of employees
at one location
and the company provided the ability to
do this to its employees as a perk
because how convenient is it for an
employee not to have to worry about
shuffling around on the weekends or
moving cars around before after work or
getting daycare while you move cars
around
it was very good for the employees
obviously the employees paid for the car
service but the fact that the employer
made it available was a great was a
great perk
and so in the course of doing this it
was a great business model that took off
had a bit of a bump during covid when a
lot of large companies started having
people not work at the office anymore uh
but that of course will will turn back
around to some degree
but the number one request that they had
from their customers was hey while my
vehicle is there and while you're
changing the oil can you do a state
inspection too
as it turns out our state statutes on
state inspections were developed at a
time when uh the idea was a brick and
mortar station so the the current rules
and laws that we have on motor vehicle
inspections contemplate there being a
brick and mortar location so we worked
with
the
state of new hampshire department of
safety division of motor vehicles
and the auto dealers as well just in
terms of addressing some of their
concerns and i'm sure they'll be
testifying afterwards i don't want to
speak for them but i think the biggest
concern was all right this is a nice
concept but we certainly want to have a
level playing field we don't want some
guy in a pickup truck with a bag of
tools uh coming to a company and saying
hang on doing your inspections so there
has to be some criteria that make it as
similar process as it can be for a brick
and mortar location and so if you look
at the bill
it's kind of set up that way first of
all the first thing we do is define what
a mobile service garage is uh senator
waters covered some of those things i
think one of the the key things is roman
numeral number one on on line six has to
have a lift involved you have to be able
to pick up the vehicle to be able to
look underneath it so a vehicle lift of
at least nine thousand pounds a guy in a
pickup truck with a bag of tools is not
gonna have that as a part of his uh his
vehicle
uh various other things i'll point out
line uh 12 which is roman numeral five i
think representative thompson asked this
question about the uh that data there
the current rules on inspection stations
say they have to be 12 feet by 25 feet
so again to make a level playing field
we copied that um but yes the sides fold
out the vehicle as it goes down the
street is a typical trailer pulled by in
this case the one out front is a
1 500
i assume it's a
dodge 1500
f150 i mean 3500 i'm sorry so um either
an f-350 or a 3500 type pickup truck
uh it's one ton truck
so um so in the trailer uh when expanded
when the sides come out uh is 12 feet by
25 feet
the the next one down roman numeral 6
talks about unobstructed work areas
which is also addressed in the current
rule so tried to make these so they
address all the rules that a brick and
mortar inspection station would have to
cover as well in addition line 16 talks
about insurance policy with liability
limits of a million dollars at least um
and the business has to have an
insurance policy those are actually
requirements that do not apply to brick
and mortar stations but they make a lot
of sense and then importantly on line 22
the business that operates the mobile
service garage has to have an office a
physical office located somewhere that's
staffed at regular posted hours
and provides access to the state
inspection records so the department of
motor vehicles can go check and see
what's been done but also importantly
that has a schedule for the next seven
days so a inspection officer can
actually go pay an unannounced visit to
one of these units
and it could be anytime in the next
seven days or it could not happen at all
but they have the ability to look ahead
and see for the next seven days where
they're going to be so they can help
you know stop by and just check things
out randomly so
uh the rest of page one just deals with
signage and then um the the last page
deals with um
how it works operationally and this is
where it talks about line uh you know
five and six says the director can
establish allow these mobile service
garages to do state inspections um
seven and eight says has to be
why the mobile service garage is at the
employer's location uh and we don't have
a problem by the way with any changes to
that that might restrict it to a you
know certain number of contiguous days
it would certainly even for the largest
company you'd be normal in five days
because obviously the weekend things are
done
so uh item b there is the inspections
can only be done on vehicles registered
to employees of the company so i can't
bring my neighbor's car uh to work with
me one day and have work done on them
for that um if the company happens to
have vehicles that could be done on
those vehicles as well though um and
then um
the have to post the uh the costs and um
that's the last part of it so try to
make it a level playing field for
existing auto dealers while also
providing a service uh and a benefit to
employees of large companies
and uh i'd be happy to answer any
questions or if you want to hear from mr
mcclay first and we can both answer
questions up to you mr chair
we'll do questions first sure if there
are any any questions from the committee
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
are these these mobile units how often
well first of all
who is certifies that
these are legitimate
units
and how often are they a second question
is how often
are they inspected
so the certification as of right now so
these are currently operating doing
regular maintenance on vehicles um and
there's a little to no regulation on
them for that regard in terms of
performing state inspections they would
have to be one authorized by the
department of motor vehicles
and
then subject to all auditing and
inspections that any car dealer or
inspection station now would be and i
don't know and i'm they're here to
testify afterwards i'm not sure if
there's a regular annual thing that has
to happen or just subject to random
inspections thank you
for the questions
you have a question representative
horrigan
yes or an opinion actually it's kind of
a repeat of what i asked senator waters
but you may be in better
better position to answer it so i
noticed in
mr mclay's later letter he
he uh mentioned he's been working with
um
at dartmouth-hitchcock medical center
which is a place i've a little bit
familiar with because i worked there for
a few months and that has
very many many different entities who
employ people actually in my case i was
just working for a temp agency but they
have like
dartmouth hitchcock medical center the
dartmouth medical school a host of other
entities so
um
i guess you what we would envision is um
they would probably they could probably
would they be able to contract with uh
multiple entities that are co-located at
the same location if they're working at
a place like that so that each each of
those different um
employers could contract separately with
this vendor to provide the inspection
services um
thank you for the question
representative horgan and i'll
let rick if he wants to after he goes
through his
testimony address that as it's written
now it has to be certainly be it's one
employer so if there are employees of a
temporary employees that belong to
another company they wouldn't be
eligible as it's written and if it was
dartmouth college versus
dartmouth-hitchcock medical center
then i believe those are two separate
clients that we have and obviously with
two distinct but
close locations
thank you for taking my question follow
up on rep horrigans so on the second
page you said um
uh only employers
uh registered to the employee who's
enforcing that
uh that's a good question in fact that's
uh
that's a good question
i don't know i don't know if there's a
good way
and i think the dmv had raised this in
terms of
in the senate hearing and i think we
discussed that a number of issues that
are outstanding could be probably
addressed by rules but that would be one
of the trickier ones is you probably
need the
employer to somehow certify that
employee ids would work a larger company
obviously you'd have that situation so i
ran a number of small companies and
nobody had an employee id but
it's a good rule-making issue though
thank you for the question for the
questions from the committee
representative thompson
good afternoon and uh thank you for
taking my question
doesn't this business have a somewhat
limited um
potential
i mean
i don't know how many companies there
are in new hampshire currently and
probably you do if you've done any
market research
that would avail themselves of this
service
thank you for the question i i
personally don't know um and perhaps mr
mcclay certainly isn't from the upper
valley so he has a good sense of what's
going on in the upper valley but yeah
there are um you're talking you have to
have a you know a certain base of
employees to make this
uh worthwhile for the mobile service
garage to stop by for let's say a day uh
and try to shoot them all in and i know
that they currently do that different
companies they will have it for
different periods of time so perhaps mr
mcclay can address that as he talks
about it
and one follow-up sir follow-up
um
what is the uh
what is the potential
that you could do in a day with one of
these units how many
valid inspections could you do i'll let
mr mcclay address that too as he goes
through his presentation okay
thank you very much that means i don't
know
[Laughter]
any further questions
seeing none the floor is yours thank you
sir
walsh and the committee for allowing me
to testify in support of sb 389
that allows mobile service garages
that
the ability to offer employer partners
their employees
new hampshire safety inspections
look i've handed out i won't go through
it line by line but i'm an automotive uh
person i've owned new car dealerships in
the state of vermont
i've been certified for state inspection
so i know a lot about
how how all inspections work in 20
2020 i had the opportunity to purchase
the
upper valley or the
which is the only where i operated is
out of the upper valley oh by the way i
am a hanover resident um
so in
in
2020 i purchased this operation because
i thought being a car person it was a
great thing for
me i always had customers had to come to
me
they in other words you build a building
and they come to you and you spend all
this money trying to get
them to come to you
so i like the concept of going to them
i also like i
don't
i
we do some home visits we do detailing
but we don't use big trailers for that
we we don't use the big trailers for
doing mechanical we have box trucks for
that that go to mechanical for small you
know one on
the trailers are not good at all
for individual
a piecemeal
the concept is you go somewhere where
you can aggregate customers
and those customers keep that trailer
and that personnel assigned to that
trailer uh busy
because otherwise it's not economically
feasible
to have that very expensive trailer
sitting there doing nothing
uh so our challenge is to try to find a
way to aggregate
customers
uh and as as
uh peter had mentioned the this was uh
this particular business model was born
at dartmouth college at the tuck
school of business
and
what they did is they came up with the
idea of
having agreements with employers
and the employer would want to do it as
an hr in other words they'd want to do
it as a benefit they could say well you
work here we can get your car fixed
along that line
we don't bil our employer
partners do not pay us
the employees pay us
so
so we so we are able to work an
agreement where they're willing to allow
us to come on their facility
with restrictions we do have uh fairly i
got i got one here
our our partner agreement is i don't
know how many pages this is but it's
15 20 page 10 15 pages or something like
that it's very legalistic it's it tries
to foresee any possible problem
it didn't foresee it doesn't foresee um
being licensed by the state to do a
particular restricted
process or uh like the state inspection
so when we enter so so we're already
doing business with people for example
today uh we communicate with our
customers by text and software
through an app
uh this morning just might have been an
act of god or something i don't know i
got a text from a customer asking if
they could get a range first inspection
this is not unusual
so we already have people that come to
us it'd be like
i don't know if i was in vermont and i
was inspect i was servicing a new
hampshire car
i couldn't do a new hampshire inspection
in vermont
so that vermont that new hampshire
customer that was loyal to me had to go
to new hampshire had to leave me so the
same thing is true now i have loyal
customers
um that
are at employ most again we do some
at-home stuff but not much
these employers
allow us
um
so what happens with that type of
customer that is our loyal customer
they
we actually oftentimes have us look at
the car we do a health check and we find
safety issues right and then they can
either get it fixed but we can't put it
we can't inspect it we can't fail it or
pass it we can only say this is a safety
issue would you like your brakes are bad
or you know that kind of thing so um um
so what our customers have to do is
either they get it fixed and they go to
an inspection station and either it
passes or it doesn't pass
uh and then they've either got to get it
fixed there so it's it's sort of
in the long and short of it very
inconvenient for the person who owns the
car
uh the the the employee of these uh
business partners we have and i think
i'll rather than ramble on i think i
think it's to me it's about do you want
me to try to answer some of these
questions okay um
so the employer partners is very
structured uh and
um
well first of all if you went to a
single a person that had two employees
and and and
said here's a 15
[Music]
lawyer
agreement right
he'd probably go no no we'll just we
just come by and take you know inspect
so we don't do that we would if they
don't want to engage in our contract
then we won't engage with them and
there's no echo
it's like going to somebody's house and
doing two cars you could not afford to
bring these trailers
um to do that uh um the
the question i think was um um
so for example in the upper valley we
have dartmouth college
we have a separate agreement with
dartmouth college
we have a dartmouth uh dartmouth medical
center um uh
mary hitchcock
we have a separate agreement
uh
dartmouth
mary hitchcock um dartmouth it's called
dartmouth hitchcock so i've separate
agreement with dartmouth
that stands by itself and i have a
separate agreement with uh hitchcock
um and then they they have a aspect day
in lebanon new hampshire which is
another hospital which is operated by
mary hitchcock i have an addendum to the
mary hitchcock
agreement that allows those people there
at apd we have other companies that are
listed hypertherm uh adamab uh by excel
are
really small relatively s i mean
they're not big uh hitchcock is big
right and hitchcock would be the their
5000 cars there three to five thousand
cars
seven days a week we're open five days a
week but
that's the target
that that particular large employer and
they do have employee ids we don't now
we pick up the cars at stake hitchcock
or dartmouth
we the car the key exchange is done
through a kiosk which is on site
so and they park
in permitted parking in other words you
can't park in any of those facilities
without a permit in fact we even have
shuttle vehicles that quite often get
ticketed unless we put a sign in because
that
identifies us because we have a multiple
vehicles running around so we they don't
require us to have a sticker for each
vehicle but anyway so if a
a citizen of
a
town down the 30 miles away decided they
wanted to pretend to be a
hitchcock customer
they would have to park their car
because you can't come our our stations
we don't receive customers it's all
it's all um
no contact um so it's all done online uh
we we
in the case of the employee partners
there's kiosk exchanges that they've so
they've got not only got to park there
they've got to get in the building and i
don't know if you've been into any of
the
well i don't know here it seems easier
to get in a building than it does back
in
in hanover
you can't get in in hitchcock you cannot
get
you can't get three feet into the
building before somebody's turning you
away if you don't have an appointment
hitchcock everything's dartmouth is all
locked up i mean you know you can't
anyways it's very restrictive the other
travel which doesn't works well for us
because we're no no we're no non-contact
so i don't know uh so
i think that they're all good questions
and i think probably
probably uh dmv will probably come up
with some ways to word it so
like i'm telling you what we do
now this law would allow anybody to do
what we do
and i guess but we wouldn't have uh the
inspection process was a question you
had
um it takes and i
it takes an hour to an hour and a half
to perform a state inspection
um i suppose if it's a brand new car you
might be able to trim that a bit
right if it's an older car it could take
longer so if you're working uh you
usually these trailers only have one
person
so and and he's got that one person's
got to go get the cars right so he's if
he's working eight hours
uh he's probably got an hour or two just
shuttling cars
so i guess it leaves four or five right
so um
and then of course if the car fails
inspection it needs break work and other
stuff
uh that that all take time so it's not
like it's
we we would we would probably assume
we're gonna do one or two a day right um
but
again it's it's um
yeah we
same sections don't really work that way
you know you just don't line them up
most most dealerships
they're doing other stuff they're doing
oil changes and they're doing whatever
uh and then i think i don't know did i
miss any i think you i think you've got
all the questions i think you did a
great job thank you
um i think he did a good job answering
all the questions that were raised
before are there any others from the
committee
representative gorski thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question yeah um you mentioned you know
when inspection sometimes if it's brakes
you can repair them but what happens if
it's uh a ball tire i don't think these
trailers have you know tires for all
vehicles so what would happen in that
instance
we don't have any parts on the trailer
so what we have is local parts vendors
we call them up or text them or order
online tires brakes and they deliver
them to us
representative hill
thank you mr chairman um just a quick
question um my
my question is uh do you need um
inter uh internet in order to connect
with dmv or something like that and and
how are you doing that in
some of the areas that are
somewhat spotty
well again that goes to mobile if we're
out
if we're at a major employer the major
employers especially the ones i'm
talking about in my area they all have
the internet is not a problem if i was
go you know 20 miles out internet's a
problem and we're not likely to go
there's no big employers 20 miles out
now we just
our plan is to probably do what we do
here
in the upper valley and then move
somewhere near nashua we'll have another
operation that will start up in
nashville that general area
which have bigger employers and and
some of the economics work out a little
better than in the upper valley the
reason it's in the upper valleys that's
where it was started
thank you
i just have one question sometimes don
needs to break over marblehead but
you say you've been doing this you have
contracts you have contracts with this
people those people these people how can
you be doing all these inspections
before we even pass this law
we don't do inspections you're not so
you're doing all these agreements right
now just for service yep
really okay interesting
representative thompson
um i guess my question is how
are your employees compensated is this
piece work
hourly
hourly hourly okay
that's that's my question thank you very
much thank you did you have your hand up
representative
thank you for taking my question two
quick questions how many companies are
currently doing this right now are you
the are you the sole company doing this
doing state section doing this mobile
no i think they're a lot but i mean
around the country no i'm talking about
new hampshire
i don't know that i know we i don't know
that i know that i know other people
have purchased trailers
and what they're doing with them i don't
know um but
um
so i don't i don't know
just one more one more question so you
said you had one technician
in the the van um brick and mortar
stores often have a technician and then
a service advisor double checks their
work to make sure nothing was missed or
make sure maybe they didn't need that
part is there anyone double checking the
work or is this the sole person saying
hey you need brakes
and maybe they missed something so it
totally relies on them
yeah the model is not a brick and mortar
model it's not a we're not i'm not a
brick i no longer have a brick operation
some people may have a brick operation
and they use the mobile as a way to
retain customers or to be competitive or
like i said if you could go if when i
had brick if i had
the trailer design and all the software
and the processes to do this that would
have been something i could have done
so somebody could be in the brick
business and then have the
so to answer your question about
personnel though
so the model is that the trailer or the
box truck or the van or whatever the
person's working out of
uh
the customer schedules their own
appointments
so we don't you don't call up and
schedule an appointment you create a you
go online you create a
customer profile
and you
select from a
list of
services and you choose what you want
and then you choose your schedule
right so you don't sorry to interrupt
that so the question was basically who's
double checking the technician's work so
we've had
safety inspection bills come through and
the issue was you know they're charging
more for you know brakes when the car
didn't need brakes who's checking this
one individual
doing the service if i can answer that
forum just to save some time there are a
lot of shops excuse me sir
there's a lot of shops that are just
individual proprietors as well there's
nobody checking their work either so i
don't know that this this this business
i guess it would be me or my right
exactly my mechanic nobody's checking
over his uh his work yeah because we
would know by complaining well we know
if by complaints from customers
if a customer was to complain to a third
party let's say in this case dmv
right the hope would be we knew about it
before they had to complain to be in tv
but sometimes customers
um
are frustrated so they'll reach out to a
higher power and then usually what
happens is we get engaged with the
customer and our people are human they
make mistakes the question is whether
they're mistakes that
if they're reoccurring for example we
would know dmv wouldn't know but if we
know we have a problem with somebody
then we have to manage it otherwise it
becomes our problem and
okay yeah thank you very much
representative value
thank you mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my question um do we really want
to restrict this to just
contracted services
or i mean it sounds like it would be a
great idea for like jiffy lube or
dealers to
get one of these vehicles and contract
with walmart and set up in the parking
lot and
do a remote service on occasion
do we really want to
have some kind of a protectionist
clause in there that restricts us to
just that contracted services
uh thank you for the question so uh this
idea has come up before about and i
remember a conversation with
representative hunt
who at the time i was in senate was one
of my constituents out in rindge
and
he thought it'd be great if anybody
could just do this um
drive around with a trailer and a pickup
truck and a box of tools so i understand
the
desire by some but it also has to be
something that is
uh the dmv feels that they can regulate
and oversee and still maintains a level
playing field so those are certainly
ideas for consideration um
but at least the the model that's
currently being used seemed to be the
one to imitate first and then see how
that goes
if i may miss the chair just addressed a
couple of things that came up quickly so
are there others in new hampshire that
are doing this so prior to covid uh the
company that founded this the the
company that came out of dartmouth tuck
school of business was called zipity
and they were doing work in the upper
valley in the nashua area the seacoast
area also massachusetts and texas
when the pandemic hit um business
uh dried up uh or significantly um and
they carved off very various pieces of
it and so rick's company now has the
upper valley area other people have
bought other units uh what they plan to
do with them i don't know but i'm gonna
guess if they've invested in the units
they plan to use them uh and some of
them i know have been bought by actual
dealerships um so there are others going
on in new hampshire whether they're
active now or not i think they're
preparing to be and that regards the
question about internet connectivity
that's why line 11 is there on the first
page uh it has to have internet
connectivity to be able to do state
inspections if it doesn't can't do state
inspections
thank you both very much
uh next up fair recognizes dan bennett
from the hampshire auto dealers
association
in support of the bill looking for two
minutes
no it did not
you're down to one
uh good afternoon or morning member of
the committee dan bennett new hampshire
auto dealers association as you know our
trade association representing the motor
vehicle industry
about 500 businesses um statewide both
franchised and independent folks in the
motor vehicle industry um
so we do support sb389 um but with a
concern or suggestion that senator wan
waters mentioned earlier um we do
appreciate all the um the amendments and
changes and considerations that have
have been made in this bill over the
three or so years that it's been
discussed um they're focused on consumer
protection uh level playing field and
importantly um agency accountability and
enforcement so um we are very sensitive
to how this bill has evolved over the
years
but the concern of suggestion that we'd
like to bring up is that a mobile
inspection unit should be truly mobile
um and that's something that should be
defined uh if a food truck
goes and and camps out in front of a
local restaurant in town for six months
they'd probably say something right so
um we just want to um and provide it for
for dmv um you know there's gonna be an
intense amount of rule making that's
gonna have to go into this
um
to making you know this this bill and
law become a reality on on the ground um
you've mentioned some of them already to
be addressed in rule making so
to make it you know easier on dmv um
please set the policy to determine what
is truly mobile
and how often it does need to move or
return to home base
we have no issue with mobile units
mobile service
as mentioned it happens all the time
heavy trucks construction and farm
equipment are repaired in the field
uh
so mobile service does occur um
so that would be one of the things uh
representative fenton raises a good
concern also to be considered for
rulemaking um and and you may want to
entertain that as well is how do you
ensure that i don't just grab my
neighbor's car and bring it in with me
so um
rather than having 235 236 towns set
their own definition of mobile
please provide that guidance to the dmv
and let them know what those constraints
um
constraints should be um and then just
to mention one of the comments that i've
heard from the video
one of the reasons that you don't just
want someone doing a pop-up shop in
walmart is because of of customer
consumer protection and and customer
accountability so what if that person
does or that inspection does do
something um
you know uh as a violation um there's
there's nowhere to go back to how do you
find them um if it's just a pop-up so
that's the one of the reasons i believe
consumer protection was a concern in the
various different versions of this bill
to get there to not have that that wide
open
option
so um
i guess i will in trying to move through
my testimony as as quickly as i can um i
guess i'll just end there and let you
know again
we do support the legislation uh we just
would like to see uh some further
definitions put in there so that the the
dmv can undertake that rulemaking and
have your guidance in setting that with
that policy
okay
representative o'hara
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question just a quick question
to uh for your association what would be
a fair number of
days for this to be a truly mobile
entity
uh i think that's probably a discussion
so i don't have an answer to that
question representative thank you for
the question uh i think that's probably
something to be discussed um
for you all as committee policy members
but also maybe the
one of the vendors who's here um you
know as well as importantly dmv what
what is the the um
state police troop g or the automotive
equipment inspectors whose
responsibility it is to go out and
inspect these units audit these units
ensure that technicians are
licensed and probably conducting safety
inspections what would their level of
comfortability be as to um the
accountability of that unit so their
input i think would be critical
representative did i see your hand up no
no
thank you just messing with me
any other questions from the committee
cnn thank you very much thank you all
very much uh that's the last person i
have signed up to speak on 389 is there
anybody else here that wishes to
seeing that i'm going to close the
public hearing on senate bill 389
uh just to let you know where we're at
um i'm going to take a break for say 10
minutes we have one more bill to take up
i don't even see the prime sponsor here
before lunch
uh which is senate bill
um i'll try to reach her in the meantime
i this is the time i had built up to
potentially uh exactly two early bills
that we have the first thing this
morning but i do know we are waiting for
an amendment on one of them so
we'll uh and take a 10 minute hear the
last bill and then perhaps go outside
and check out this trailer before it
leaves so give me give me 10 minutes
all right welcome back everybody
everything
i'm going to open up the public hearing
on senate bill 309
it is authorizing certain organizations
to issue decal plates
prime sponsor is senator richardy but i
believe
somebody's here to introduce the bill
for her
thank you chairman walsh and members of
the transportation committee i'm carol
alfano i am the communications director
for the senate it's my privilege to
introduce senate bill 309 for senator
denise ricciardi who represents senate
district 9 which is comprised of 15
towns from bedford to sharon
i'm introducing senate bill 309
authorizing certain organizations to
issue decal plates
this bill would allow the new hampshire
towing association
and jesus across the border to issue
decals for their organization for
multi-use license plates if you are not
familiar with decal plates the state
issues a special license plate with an
area that approved decals may be placed
the organization issues the decal this
is typically done by the organization as
a way to get more recognition and help
with fundraising
currently there are 17 different
organizations that have approved decals
including the boy scouts the
professional firefighters the new
england patriots charitable foundation
and the knights of columbus including a
couple others the new hampshire towing
association is a non-profit organization
dedicated to working with the state
legislature and the state along with
local law enforcement to improve wrecker
operations throughout the state of new
hampshire their intent is to use this
decal as a way to promote and raise
awareness for new hampshire's move over
law
i am not familiar with the other group
jesus across the border but i am sure
there is someone else that may be able
to testify or maybe jesus himself can
speak to you about what they do thank
you for considering this bill and
senator uh rashardi uh appreciates it as
well thank you for listening
thank you very much actually i don't
have anybody uh nor do i see jesus here
so
the question i did have was on that one
do you know if it's at least a 501 c 3 8
or 10
do you know if it complies with what's
in the statute for requirements it's my
understanding somewhere from diop
did you say it wasn't fabulous
we don't
we're not we are unsure if it's a fight
okay fair enough thank you very much
okay thank you
uh skip stearns from new hampshire
towing association i'm assuming
in support of the bill
yes sir my name is skip stearns i own
skips towing in londonderry i'm a board
of director for the new hampshire
tournament associate have been for like
35 years
we want it for safety education
and awareness if we can save one life
with this plaque we've done our job
it's very difficult
loading your 100 000 mercedes on a side
of 93 when everybody's doing 75 miles an
hour six inches from us
and we just need it there's one more
little tool in our belt if you're going
down the road and you see this decal and
it makes you think and you move over
um
thank you very much would you take any
questions
yep that is the last person i have
signed up to speak on senate bill 309
anybody else
wish to did you have a question
i think we will probably discuss it at a
later time because i don't think there's
anyone to take my questions yeah fair
enough thank you we will not be
executing this today so we have time
uh with uh seeing no one else to speak
to the bill i'm gonna close the public
hearing on senate bill 309
and as i said before i originally had
built this time in to exact the two
early bills we're going to do it at the
end of the day waiting for uh
waiting amendments and it actually gives
us an opportunity to take a few minute
extra longer lunch and go check out this
mobile service garage if you care to i
believe it's out front
in the plaza so we'll see you after
lunch
as scheduled one o'clock senate bill 311
like i tell everybody
okay
so we have
one at the time being one o'clock
and our chair
um testifying in the senate
uh i've been handed the gavel for senate
bill 311
and i believe the senator is
tied up
that would introduce it but we do have a
suitable representation representative
for the senator
chantelle wheeler
welcome to
house transportation
thank you good afternoon members of the
committee my name is chantal wheeler i
am here on behalf of senator sharon
carson who represents senate district 14
the towns of hudson londonderry and
auburn i am here to introduce senate
bill 311
which permits motor vehicle-related
businesses and healthcare providers to
obtain personal information from
driver's license or non-drivers
identification cards with the consent of
the license holder provided that the
businesses meet certain restrictions
regarding the collection retention and
retention of such information and use of
such information
would you mind saying that again
i can yeah
that's fine
i'm i'm assuming
you don't want to take questions or i
would prefer not to okay i would like to
defer questions great
not a problem thank you very much for
your help
we do have
two pink cards at this moment um
i would call the honorable neil kirk
and welcome him to house transportation
to see you
members of the committee for the record
i'm neil kirk i live in the town of
where and i'm here representing myself
um
i oppose um senate bill 311
for the following reasons
uh first you'll notice that there are
two parts
uh of substantive changes
um page 1 line 25 section d which deals
with
access to motor vehicle records for
quote motor vehicle related business
purposes
and then
part e on page 2 line 14
which deals with access to the same
records for health care business
purposes
okay
right now
in statute we have very carefully
restricted access to driver's records
for privacy reasons
the purpose of
the database all the motor vehicle
records is for motor vehicle purposes
for the state not for anyone else
this bill makes some exceptions to that
the first one
and this is um
i'm referring to lines page 1
lines 25 to 28
with the
license holders consent
the information on the cord can be
scanned photocopied recorded retained or
stored
and it's for motor vehicle related
business purposes motor vehicle business
related business purposes is undefined
so
that would include an automobile
dealership you know when you go to test
drive a car you're supposed to give a
copy of your license it would apply to
my local
garage that fixes cars because that's
motor vehicle related
it would apply to
riley's auto and snell auto and all of
these auto
replacement parts businesses
it would apply to a bank
which gives
motor vehicle-related loans
um this is very broad
and
i'm not sure what the policy is or isn't
behind this
but it's it's clear to me that this
needs to be delineated and restricted if
there is a valid reason for allowing
these folks to scan and copy this now
i will admit that the use of the
information is quite restricted in the
rest of the section d and e
however
let's go to section e which does the
same thing for health care business
purposes
what's health care
well certainly if i go to
dartmouth-hitchcock clinic or concord
hospital or my local doctor
but what about walmart or cvs
or walgreens
can they do this also in other words
again this is a term that is so broad
that it would include almost everybody
and then as a result of that
we're going to have copies of our
licenses in a very significant
proportion of the businesses in this
state is that what we think should
happen to motor vehicle licenses is that
why i got a license from the state
the problem is that people have come to
use driver's licenses for identification
purposes and because we've put in
protections
they want those
deleted there's one other point that i'd
like to make to you
there's a difference between section
d which deals with motor vehicle related
purposes and section e which deals with
health care related purposes and that's
on page 2
line 20.
when it comes to health care
if i refuse to give my consent because
remember they can only get my license if
i consent to it
it says there is no consequence to the
holder who declines to provide such
consent
and guess what there isn't
in part d dealing with motor vehicle
related businesses if i refuse and i
have the right to refuse
to give my driver's license to these
folks when they request it they can say
neil there's the door out you go
we won't provide you with any of our
services
i'm not sure why that was not put in
there but it
might have been an oversight i suspect
it was intentional
um i think you need to put if this bill
is going to pass at the very least that
section two needs in that's in section e
needs to be added to section d
that said
that's if you pass the bill i still
think this is
an
unnecessary
intrusion
or misuse of the motor vehicle
department database and driver's
licenses
but if somebody makes a case that it is
an appropriate use
and you buy that case then at the very
least
you need to add section 2e
to section d
that completes my testimony mr chairman
i'd be pleased to answer any questions
if committee members have them
thank you honorable kirk
does the committee have questions
seeing none i think you're off the hook
thank you sir thank you
we'll see in a few minutes yes
i do have one other pink card uh from
the new hampshire hospital association
um
paula monaghan minute hand close hand
i think this is my first time here
really
welcome
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee for the record paula
minihan senior vice president state
government relations for the new
hampshire hospital association
representing all our hospitals and we
are in strong support of senate bill 311
and we do thank senator carson and
senator waters for agreeing to sponsor
this piece of legislation
as well as representatives pearson and
penta laykas um i am specifically
testifying on paragraph e which does
amend rsa 263 colon 12 roman 10 to
provide appropriate flexibility for
organizations to scan and store a
driver's license for legitimate business
purposes while protecting the
individual's information
and i will um i'll try not to read my
testimony because i'm handing it out but
i do want to explain
this is
protected information and we did make
actually pretty significant changes in
the senate to address um
concerns raised by representative kirk
so i um i was hoping that
at least our section would be more
amenable um but we did make some changes
regarding consent we made changes
um that to protect um this was actually
in the senate to ensure that as he
stated no matter what if they decline or
not you still receive
you're still going to receive care which
of course they would but we wanted to be
explicit
we also made changes to ensure that the
the holder may request the removal of
the driver's license so honestly three
four um
items two
four
um two three four we made a lot of
changes in the senate to this bill i'm
just going to
say that to address the concerns um and
the the reason the hospitals need this
and cannot do it now but they need to
scan the license the drive the ids
to increase patient safety and to reduce
fraudulent activities
currently they are unable to scan and
store these licenses or non-driver ids
which is a legitimate business practice
which is actually a hipaa term so that
is where that
health
information privacy and protection act
it aids in deter deterring identity
misrepresentations in which individuals
use the name and insurance information
of another individual to fraudulently
obtain medical services it's it it
happens and they need to prevent that
it ensures that similarly named
individuals with very similar names and
dates of birth have correct medical
information throughout the course of
their
health care services which i'm sure you
can appreciate
and it prevents individuals from
obtaining drugs under someone else's
name and again i won't read my testimony
but we did work with the health
information managers at the hospitals
that requested this um legislation for
those reasons because they are not
hypotheticals they are they are real um
they are they're real
real instances that this has occurred
and then i reference the federal trade
commissions red flag rules which require
hospitals to do these reasonable to have
reasonable policies and procedures in
place
to again identify and respond to
identity theft called red flags that's a
federal that's an ftc thing
um
and that the inability to
to do this has been has been a barrier
um let's see
um
then legitimate as i mentioned um
legitimate business purposes hipaa um
the
health information insurance portability
and accountability act um allows for
that
um am i
trying to shut my phone um multiple do
we have multiple rules and regulations
in place to ensure patient privacy
um and to ensure that again they're not
being
incorporated into the medical records
and that is
even though that was our original
testimony we made it very explicit in
the amended bill
we do
believe that all hospitals should employ
the employee the opportunity to use
driver's licenses and non-driver id to
fulfill the purposes of proper patient
identification and fraud reduction
and we do believe that this bill
provides the proper scope to allow this
access to while also protecting the
patient's privacy
um and just just as a little background
um it was at when the bill was um
initially introduced in the in the bill
and excuse me in the senate the first
section was not included but the auto
dealers association which obviously i do
not represent but um they requested that
first section they requested an
amendment um and so that's where that
first section comes from and um
i know dan from the uh auto dealers was
very involved in in um draft helping to
draft that area of of the bill
um so
um i just wanted to mention that just
for the record
i'm happy to answer any questions thank
you very much thank you um are there
questions
uh representative sykes
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question of course um
i'm i'm trying to wrap my head around
the fact that what what is to stop you
from
requesting the information from the
patient in other words can i see your
driver's license
and then checking a box that says you
checked his driver's license but not
necessarily holding on to
um you know a photocopy of that license
i i don't see
i don't see the connection there
they they need to check um again the to
do the red you need to have reasonable
policies and procedures in place and so
the health information managers stated
that that was necessary to do that check
with to verify um that in fact the
individual um is in fact
there has not been an issue like they
didn't lose their license for instance
if i walk in to concord hospital with my
my insurance card and my id
but my but i'm not paula minihan um i'm
someone else but i have that information
they can check the database to make sure
that in fact it hasn't been stolen for
instance
yeah yeah i would like to follow up so
you explain to me what you might do with
this information but you didn't explain
to me why you needed to have the
information i understand you need to
check to make sure the person standing
in front of you is that person
to prevent fraud to make sure that the
pa the right patient is getting the
right care
what what i don't
the the pieces of the dots that are not
connected is why do you have to keep a
copy
of that record
they are it's being it's not being put
in the medical record and that is
specifically stated they are they are
making sure that because they will be
getting treated by more than one one
place necessarily so i can get you more
clearly from the experts um but again
they had stated that in order to follow
the ftc requirements they need to
they are on they don't scan it now
um but if you go from place to place
within the hospital for instance it's a
better example you're not having to ask
for that id every single time because
it's in the system as you're making your
way through the system but it's not in
the medical record
let me give a shot at this okay
so you ask for the id initially
and
if the the patient could perhaps
decline
doesn't affect his care right or her
care right
um at any time they could ask
their id
copy to be removed from
the system the hospital system not their
records but the system right
and yet um
i don't know why
anyone would comply
um
how does how does this benefit the
patient i guess that might would be my
question
it's protecting the patient's identity
and and records to make sure that
um like i said one of the reasons they
need this is if ma if there is a as you
said paula monahan versus paula minihan
i want to make sure that my record is
not in paula monahan's record that i'm
in paula minihan's record so it is to
ensure that similarly named individuals
with with similar names and date of
birth have the correct medical
information used throughout the course
of their health care services so it's
really it is a it's a patient protection
um
effort and that's why the federal trade
commission um put in these what they
call red flag rules to um ensure that
identity
theft is not occurring and this is one
one tool that they are using
thank you you're welcome and just to be
clear uh representative you could
request that it be removed but we did um
add that not unless legal action
concerning the holder is underway then
that could not be removed that is on
line 29 or legal action concerning the
holder be underway and senator birdsell
and
senator carson agreed to add that
language in there so just wanted to be
clear because that does happen as well
but i'm happy to follow up with the
committee and get more information as to
the
the um the necessity for this because i
i represent hospitals but
lots and lots of very smart people work
at hospitals and the health information
managers are the ones that have been
asking for this actually we tried to do
this through um
through the department of safety through
rule making not rule making but we um
through rules it allows for exceptions
to be made they actually asked us to
make the changes in the in this um
statute versus just asking them for an
exception so we did actually try that
last summer and that's um why we
we came up with this approach and
senator carson agreed to sponsor it
thank you um i have one further question
and and i'm not sure if you're the right
person because you are representing the
hospital association but you've probably
heard um a previous
uh testimony mentioned that um it seemed
overly broad for the healthcare business
purposes
was that mentioned in senate testimony
as well
the
the potential
definition of what would be encompassing
health care business purposes that is i
believe a hipaa term um so health care
for legitimate um business purpose
health care business purposes so
um i
i'm not recalling to be honest um if
that came up or not i'm trying to
remember the original again the original
bill was was different um
trying to find it
quick search didn't show that in our
rsas but i didn't know if it was it's a
i think it's more of a hipaa term
um the original bill said legitimate
business purposes again that is also
a hipaa term um but they they changed it
to health care business um or whatever
it is
that's fine that's fine
healthcare business purposes that was
changed um amended in the senate thank
you yeah representative pilerski
thank you um i'm not sure this is actual
question but just sort of i want i'm
curious about your response
obviously this is an issue of a person's
protection of their privacy
um
which actually there's our constitution
protects privacy here in new hampshire
and i'm
wondering about
what
mechanisms hospitals in new hampshire
provide
to prevent any breach of their data we
hear sometimes in the news of a data
breach where private information is um
lost is there
any concern that uh this information
would be vulnerable
i mean there's always the concern
because that's that's our the nature of
our
environment
so data breaches do occur not there have
not been any significant ones um you've
heard it in other parts of the country
but not in new hampshire per se um they
have lots and lots and lots of layers of
protection of the data um so again this
is a different database this is not your
emr this is not the electronic medical
record um i um obviously am not a the
cio of a hospital so i can't answer
specifically what safeguards they have
in place but they have many many to
protect everyone's
data but i can't i can follow up if you
want specifics but i i don't i can't
answer that question i just have one
other quick question thank you um the
only other thing i have a question about
is the um
that the holder may request the removal
of the driver's license at any time
i understand the thought process of
being able to have each department
verify
uh that kind of thing now i think we're
all used to
getting banded you know at the admission
desk or whatever and everyone checking
as you go through the process of the
phlebotomist the x-ray whatever i guess
i'm curious
how would this
change that
if you're if you're admitting someone to
a facility for process
how would this change
is this another level another layer
um
because i'm wondering sorry i don't mean
interrupt you but my question is if
someone says you know what
i i've changed my mind because i've now
pulled my license out and seen it you
know scanned or i've seen people pull it
up
how would this
significantly improve with the process
that's already in place i guess is what
i'm saying because i want people to be
able to know that they can pull back
their information
i
can again um
get that answer from the experts they
asked for this bill so um it's it's very
important to them
to protect the patient identity and
fraud detection
thank you yep
oh one more question
representative thompson
good afternoon good afternoon um
is there a requirement are you aware of
uh medicare medicaid or
the insurance companies for
production of this license
upon uh requests for medical aid
i don't know if it's a requirement like
i said the federal trade commission
requires this protection through this
red flags um
regulation so
um
certainly it would be medicare fraud if
they're if you're submitting um
fraudulent claims unknowingly submitting
them would be um have to be reviewed by
medicare and proven that you did not
realize that the individual was not who
he or she said they were
but
as i think you know the healthcare
industry is one of the most highly
regulated industries in the country
so
there are lots and lots of layers so i
don't know specifically if it's required
um but they do have to they do ask for
your your identification they just can't
scan it right now that all this is doing
is allowing for the scanning of it okay
thank you very much you're welcome thank
you uh seeing no other questions uh
thank you you survived your first time
yes yes it wasn't too bad thank you
didn't use that line anymore
thank you um i have no other pink cards
if there's anyone else
in the audience that would like to speak
on this
having seeing none i will close the
hearing
on
11. thank
you
we're already passed up no we are we do
have a chairman
a real chairman
you wouldn't like the outcome
who does that
all your other stuff
really yeah everybody else is up there
but you
so i'll do it again
good night
good for me
i know where to get it
all right being 127 i'm going to open up
the public hearing on senate bill 310
relative to license plate scanning
chair recognizes the prime sponsor
senator reagan good afternoon
thank you mr chair and members of house
transportation i'm senator john reagan
from senate district 17 and i bring to
you today senate bill 310
relative to license plate scanning
and what this does is allow private
property owner
to
purchase a license plate reader
in order to control entry
to their property
it further goes on to ban any
recording or photographing
of the occupants of the motor vehicle
that's it
any questions from the committee
representative o'hara
thank you mr chairman um i didn't fully
read over this yet but i'll ask you real
quick is there any um limitation on
retention of the license plate scan
image itself
nothing you don't retain anything okay
any other questions
i have one can you can we have a couple
examples of the types of commercial
entities that would be interested in
this
do i have any any examples of of
it just allows a private property owner
to use
your license plate as your
um
authority to enter the property okay so
it would open the gate if it matched the
plane et cetera et cetera that's it did
i see a hand down there
drop some telersky it was sort of the
same question the application of this i
could see maybe at a a gated community
or a
um an industry that had a number of
vehicles coming in i guess i'm just
trying to understand the application of
of this technology
anybody who has reason to control entry
to their property that would be
okay the reason
thank you
any other questions seeing them thank
you very much
i have nobody else signed up to speak on
senate bill 310 anybody in the audience
that wishes to do so
seeing none i'm going to close the
public hearing
my apologies i'm wondering if um mr
orbiting or someone from the dmv can
tell us what the existing rule is for
scanning a plate or tracking plates i
don't
no
he's getting up so i'll take that as a
yes slowly
i'll take a somewhat educated guess
right now it's just my understanding
it's law enforcement only i mean as far
as we're concerned we produce plates
that's what we do um as far as whether
or not they're right or not that's a law
enforcement concern
senator friend sorry thanks for taking
my question who can obtain a license
plate reader right now
my understanding is just law enforcement
employees and it's only been for a
couple of years a couple of years i
believe three
is he on this bill no no representative
thompson
um
as i understand it
even if you scan this plate and
see what it is and they say you can't
read they're not going to retain it so i
don't know how long it's available for
they're going to have to contact motor
vehicle to run the plate and you're not
going to do that for them anyway
so
there'd be no point to reading it
yeah my understanding is that if you're
in a private gated community or if you
own a private business that you would
submit your plate
to the owner of the property to submit
entry it's not something that you would
come back and do a check with us to see
whether it's valid or not we we have no
connection to that system at all and nor
would we right
i i guess i look at this in terms of
application as being a keypad or or
swiping a card to get into a certain
area
but using your license plate using your
license plate instead but again it
sounds to me it's a volunteer basis if
you want to get access quickly
to this property you submit your plate
and they read it
representative hill
thank you mr thank you mr chairman um
it seems to me that it the reader is
attached to
the vehicle not
if you read the
line 11 and 12
only installed
or mounted to a vehicle that is attended
to and operated by a law enforcement
officer
i'm confused
the way i'm reading that is that
those are the only ones that could be
attached to a vehicle the rest of them
could not that's how i see it
yeah we can discuss that later
any other questions
or did you want to look into that
no my understanding there is no
connection to our database right there
is no referencing back to us to see
whether it's a good plate or not
okay
oh and yes sorry about the pink card
seeing no other questions thank you very
much
um and again i see
nobody else here to speak unless a
representative kirk is coming up or a
former representative kurt
good afternoon
good afternoon i i hadn't intended to
speak on this but i am privy to some
information which
may be helpful to the committee
representative peter schmidt contacted
me some time ago
there's a property i believe in durham
where
a developer is proposing to build an
apartment building renting it to
students and the parking for that
parking building would be in a
private parking lot which serves a
number of other businesses
and
in order to make sure that
these new tenants didn't abuse the fact
that there was parking there
um and and make it impossible for let's
say the supermarket customers to park
um
the owner wanted to have some way to
limit
their access i don't know whether
they're these plate readers would
operate a gate or not
um but i would like to make two comments
first of all sections 9
lines 11 through 14 have nothing to do
with the purpose of this bill which is
line 15 section 3. it simply clarifies
an existing statute which says basically
only police can have access to license
plate readers and the license plate
readers have to be on the patrol cars
they can't be on the ground somewhere
they're you know a stationary unit
so
that's the the two are really separate
um someone raised the question on
section on on the
roman 3 section starting on line 15
there's nothing here that prevents
the
private person from retaining
a record of all of the vehicles that
license plates that passed through
if you don't want that to happen you
need to do some amending here
um
but as i say the purpose
the reason for this was that
under current law it was
very debatable whether a private
property owner had the legal right to
use
a scanning device even on private
property and so this was put in to
clarify that and the instant case was
the one that i mentioned in durham
i think
i've informed you as fully as i'm able
but i always want to make sure that
committees have access to the full
information so that
you make informed decisions thank you mr
chairman thank you
um okay i still see no one else wishes
to speak to
senate bill 310 so i'll close the public
hearing
it's a minute to reset and we'll go into
senate bill 406.
representative kirk could we get a pink
card for that last bill too sorry
oh
being 140 i'm going to open up the
public hearing on senate bill 406
relative to driver's license reciprocity
uh chair introduces the prime sponsors
senator birdsell
welcome
thank you mr chair it's not good to be
back
for the record my name is regina bartzel
state senator for district
19 encompassing the towns of derry
hampstead and windham
and i am the prime sponsor of senate
bill 406.
this bill was a request was put in at
the request of the department of safety
it directs the commissioner of safety to
adopt rules relative to driver education
reciprocity
including procedures for determining
whether the education
will meet the state of new hampshire's
minimum standards this bill also author
hello this bill also authorizes the
director of the division of motor
vehicles to impose uh suspensions
revocations and other limitations on a
driver convicted of
offenses
out of out of state as if such conduct
has occurred in this state and i think
the department of safety is here could
answer some of the questions that you
have about them but
i'll try and answer any questions you
may have
thank you any questions from the
committee
they're letting you off the hook seeing
them thank you thank you
that is the only
card i have for 406 did the department
of motor vehicles want to chime in or
did i lose a card
hear no speak no sino
sure
good afternoon
chairman members of the community my
name is lieutenant james larry from
troop g
my troop oversees the driver education
program
for the state of new hampshire
i honestly don't know what the history
is to the bill but i can speak to how
our out-of-state transfers are handled
currently
so if there's a student that took driver
education in another state
if they move to new hampshire prior to
obtaining their driver's license in that
state they have to meet our driver
education our standard you know our
minimum standards so in doing that right
now they submit those records to the
troop g our representative who's the
supervisor of driver education and he
ensures that they've met the proper
number of behind the wheel um the
classroom and the um observation hours
and there's also two other sections
because our state law also carves out an
hour and a half of
training around commercial motor
vehicles and an hour half speaking about
motorcycle rider safety so they need to
make sure that they meet those
qualifications as well it's my
understanding that the intent of this
bill is to help put some administrative
rule
in setting those guidelines and outlines
so that the standard whatever those
standards are essentially would be
available for someone to review so they
know exactly what the expectation is so
if they're a vermont resident they could
look at our law administrative rule and
know that these are the requirements in
order to be able to transfer the license
to new hampshire it's that's my
understanding what this is about
thank you any questions from the
committee representative o'hara thank
you mr chairman so
if i
understand you correctly what you're
basically saying is um the commissioner
can basically just write down what you
guys are doing say that's what we're
going to do and we're good at that point
i think what the thank you for your
question i appreciate that i believe
what the intent is here is to outline
what the process for that um that
transfer would be so right now it's kind
of up to someone to figure out what do i
do when i transfer my license and i'm
under the age of 18. this would outline
exactly what those pro what that step
and what those processes would look like
that's my understanding
any other question representative sykes
thank you mr chairman thank you
lieutenant
so the part that you just talked about
is actually part two and it's very it's
pretty clear to me what i
um
on departments is section two of part
one
the other the other section two driver
license compact license authority they
talk about um
when
if there's an offense in a different
state
the person could be
that this accountability in this state
is that what this is trying to get to
i guess i'm not quite sure what that is
that section is true yeah the section
two part i'm not familiar with i'm not
sure if that's something that you would
talk to
and i apologize yeah no that's right and
as i follow up i'd like to know
what are we doing now and how will this
fix it
are you talking about this the part two
yeah so i i understand you can't answer
that but thank you so i would ask the
dmv i think we'll probably be able to
give you some insight on that part of it
we knew you all should have signed up
we were going to one way or another
good afternoon brittany
bureau financial responsibility
um great questions so part two
i believe it further clarifies the
director's authority to impose sanctions
for
all the penalties which fall under the
driver licensing compact so if you
violate in another jurisdiction and
that's reported back to us it's just
further clarifying the actions that we
can apply for those individuals
for like fractions under the driver
licensing compact
that answer your question
i was walking
i i guess i'm just curious why is the
clarification necessary
for the follow-up that's the way i'm
trying
the department um again like lieutenant
o'leary said we don't know the history
behind this bill um and i can't speak to
the fact that i requested this
i specifically so it may have come from
the previous director
and i guess i have a question too and it
gets to the same thing why are we
reaffirming this because even the first
roman 2 in section 1 line 11
that's getting back to the driver's ed
and the reciprocity
if we're already doing it
i just don't understand why this is
needed because we just actually itl the
bill last year that dealt with
reciprocity but it was only the fact
that you took
the uh drivers in in another state you
didn't have to do any additional
training to make the difference up
because our course is different
i don't see that
reaffirming what we currently do i see
that as more of a way of getting back to
just a straight reciprocity meaning if
you took it in any state it's good here
do you you don't read it that way
okay
and now did you say this was also a
request to the department
i cannot confirm that like we stated
we're not sure the complete history
as i furthermore read section two of the
bottom section
with the transition to the state to
state program the driver licensing
compact there may have been discussions
as to how best handle the state to state
program that's been implemented which
again is taking the
information from one jurisdiction when
they move into our our state and again
the driver licensing compact um was
established at one point and i think
this is to support the state to state
initiatives and further clarify those
rules
with the
next section below that okay thank you
any other questions from the committee
is there anybody else that wishes to
speak to
senate bill 409 2 o'clock
okay being two o'clock
i'm going to open up the public hearing
on senate bill 449.
this is relative to the retention of
social security numbers by the division
of motor vehicles
chair recognizes the prime sponsor
senator gray good afternoon
well thank you my name is james gray
i represent uh senate district six
which starts in rochester goes up route
11 to alton and barnes said in
government in belknap county
why this bill
uh there's two things going on and we'll
start at the beginning i called up
the department and said
do you guys have
an objection to me putting in a bill
that
requires at least four digits of the
social security number to be retained
why would you want to do a thing like
that well
election integrity
that's
my thing is elections right and election
integrity how can i decide whether a
person
is qualified to vote isn't qualified to
vote if they show up because they live
under the bridge on third street
what do i do do i let him sign an
affidavit that says i am who i am
i am at least 18 years old
i am a citizen of the united states and
i am domiciled in your
town well
that's the way it is right now
there are other pieces of information
that we can go out
and access
to help a voter
whether they live under the bridge in
third street
or whether they just forgot to bring
their id with them
and want either to register to vote or
to vote
and one of those pieces of information
that
hey you know even children that are born
before tax season they need to go out
and get them a social security number
uh so that that can be put on their
taxes
and
that
would be the last four digits
the bills that were in front of the
house and senate down in washington this
year
one of the provisions in there was thou
shall not retain more than the last four
digits of the social security number
okay
i turn that around and look at it the
other way
you can retain the last four digits of
the social security number
now
as we move through the process here it
is interesting to note that right now on
the registration form
that you are asked to provide
either your driver's license number and
id
or
the last four digits social security
number
and
as we move through the process
we will contain in our own the secretary
of state's own database
more and more of that information in
those last four digits because it's
easier for people to say oh yeah it's
one two three four
it's seven eight nine ten you know or
seven eight nine one or whatever yeah i
gotta get the digits right narrow you
out you'll get
so
i call up the department and i said well
gee
we have this other program out there
that we want to use
and we would like
the last five digits
of the social security number to help us
in identifying people
so
you know investigations and
other incidents where they need to to
verify
this is fine i'll put the bill in
all right so
now
we get to people who are
very concerned about
release of information okay and social
security number has been very
sensitive information in the past
does the state have
a reason to do it
does
well when i talked to doit
they said well we don't really need
the number what we need is access to the
number
we need a program that can go in
and look into the dmv records and
compare with the number that we have
and be able to to know that it's correct
well
you know that's certainly
in the way this system
could be built or will be built
can be built into it
in some of the other committees there is
a a program out there to have an
election portal
okay
when i go pay my taxes
if i go into the state's online system
and i'm filling out my dp10
they never see my license
what do they see well
if they're trying to identify me they
may have oh here's three addresses which
one was associated with you
which of these phone numbers was yours
what is your mother's father's
grandmother's maiden name
okay
all information that's out there some of
that information i find out now that
i've looked into this
we actually
when someone goes in to get a vital
record
that there is a system that the state
does subscribe to
where
they can verify or shouldn't say verify
um
i forget the exact word but if it's
important to you you know give me an
email and i'll go go get the right word
um so it's a tool
um
is there you know
in in dealing with someone
like i say that person that lives under
the bridge on third street that lost
their license
uh you know
not because it was taken away but
physically lost the the card
um what is a piece of information
that
most everyone does know
and can help us and them make this
process efficient
and easy on them
and the thing that we came up with was
those last four digits
as we move into the portal we actually
may have other information
i tell people that
my eldest brother
was out here with his girlfriend
in 1966 and if you can tell me
who was the two people that stood up for
him when he was at dover city hall
saying i do
you know it's pretty good indication
that you know
a lot about that individual and probably
are that person
and remember most of the selection stuff
it's
if i can locate the person
um
it's it's a very good indicator that
they either a didn't do anything wrong
or
that we will be able to find out if they
did so
social security number that last four
digits is important to us
right now statute already says that
it is an element in the voter database
we want to be able to compare that
number
with the one in the dmv database
right now for people who have
a real id
that your whole social security number
and your picture are retained in that
system
but if you are only a state of new
hampshire and department i'm sure will
go into this much
better uh than i can
that there is an option on the form to
do away with
you have to supply it for your first
license but then you can ask for it not
to be retained
that causes the department problems
if we were to do a thing like that
in the three options system which is i
think one of the
amendments that was suggested on this
bill
and
i'm certainly uh willing to sit here as
long as you've got questions
thank you senator any questions from the
committee
representative oregon
oh i'm um
a little bit baffled how this interfaces
with the voting issues since there's
nothing about it in the bill but what
scenario are you trying to catch it
seems to me there's is this people who
have
get a driver's license in somebody
else's name by falsely claiming to be
them or these people who are showing up
which understands a pretty small number
who fill out uh
affidavits because they don't have um
have ids and
might also add parenthetically that
homeless people are allowed are allowed
to vote so if you live under the bridge
at third street that's a domicile like
any others so but um
so what exactly
is it that you're trying to prevent here
so if you look at the bill page one at
the bottom
and page two at the top
uh c
let me see is that's the right reference
on the request on a case by case basis
to the department of state for voter
verification identification purposes
provided that the department may only
transmit the last four digits of the
individual's number and that is the
tie-in to the voter records through that
database
so you're i'll give you one follow-up
okay
um so your belief is that there may be a
significant number of people
who
um are impersonating other people in the
voter database and if they had to know
this piece of information then the
secretary of state would have an easier
time catching them is that what the
purpose of this is no representative the
purpose of this is to make it easier for
someone who walks into the polling place
to register to vote and not have to fill
out
four different affidavits and i told you
that they were identity they were age
they were citizenship and they were
domicile on which they are filling those
affidavits out under penalty of perjury
and that the state does do
investigations into those so we will be
saving the voters time we will be saving
the state
money and time
in investigating people if we can
find a system which more easily
identifies
them to our satisfaction that they are
who they are
if they fail to bring any of those
records with them
for the questions from the committee
representative talersky thank you thank
you for taking my question senator
curious if the secretary of state or his
office had an opinion on that this was
actually needed
um i've had these discussions with the
secretary of state
over several years
certainly
the prior secretary of state was not as
uh interested in an election portal as
the current secretary of state
but i have been persistent
my vision going forward is a a system
where
an individual walks into a polling place
uh sees a line in the check-in list
can go on the portal enter their
information
uh hit a button transmit that
information to the
supervisor of the checklist the
supervisor checklist looks at their id
copies down a number the person signs
and goes votes and
there is virtually no delay
and to accomplish that
the voter identification is a very
important part of that
and so getting to that voter
identification what can i do today
today
there is
in our database in the election database
there is the last four digits if the
voter registered
after a certain time when that form was
changed to ask for it
and that that information is also in
the dmv database for people with real
ids
and hopefully through this bill it will
be available for others
in there
and that that will be a very quick and
easy way for us to get at least an
indication
to me it's probably good enough
it's as good as them signing the
affidavit without anything
to
prove that they are who they are
thank you
representative hill
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
for taking my question
um i'm assuming
that you're not asking the social
security number
to be on the license itself because
you're saying that if someone walks into
the polling place without anything
which to me means that they're walking
in without a driver's license
as long as they know the number there
would be some way
at the polling place
for that person to
verbally say what their social security
number is and that matches the
dmv is that how that works well in one
of the other bills we talk about
non-published data okay in that
application uh the person is asked for
their
uh place of birth they're asked for
their date of birth they're asked for
uh like i say either driver's license
number and state or the last four digits
of social security number all of that
information is non-published
okay and not available through rsa 91a
requests
but it is information and the
discussions that i've had with the
current secretary of state is that that
information certainly could be for the
voters in that uh polling place
uh that that could be printed on a
separate list that the
they would have
even if they didn't have internet
capability and somebody could run down
through that list very quickly
if you forgot your license
some of the other things that you'll see
possibly that
we're looking at
is
[Music]
you know other ways to to verify
uh if you go in there with your
cousin who's now living with you because
of covid or whatever
allowing one voter who has proper
identification to vouch for another one
again the purpose is to cut the list
down to make it easier on the voter to
go
register or to go vote
but to do that
some people would say that you know i'm
asking for things i shouldn't be asking
for
um i don't see it that way i think that
in the constitution where it says any
inhabitant of the state
you know has the right to vote
uh but then goes on to say once they've
established a domicile that um
you know that gives us the
the authority to go in and check for the
some of those things that
are required for people to vote
and right now
we have age
we have
citizenship
domicile
but to be able to use records to prove
that
already in statute it says you first
need to
prove your identity so that you can
prove that those records apply to you
thank you
representative sykes
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
for taking my question
this
i'm just a little bit confused this
portal that you talk about does not
currently exist
the portal bill i believe is in front of
your elections committee right now
will this
follow up please
well the changes that you are looking
for in this bill
help
if
will it work without that portal let's
say the other bill never gets through
the rest of the process
either one can be used independently
they would be much more efficient and
easier to manage should you pass them
both
there's also other bills out there that
i haven't talked about that would also
assist in that
one final sure
thank you um
has
anyone
prepared any fiscal notes to go with any
of these bills so that we know
what the cost may be in order to
implement these programs
the portal bill has a very large fiscal
note and that is
um i don't remember the exact number
uh the
people that are on that committee have
it
i could go on look it up i can look it
up thank you i appreciate it and the
reason that it is as high as it is
is that
these services that you would go to that
know your
mother's father's maiden name
okay her wife's maiden name or whatever
uh are very expensive and that if only
one department a the secretary of state
goes in and pays for that then that is a
big expense but if other departments
come online with that
or other functions come online and that
cost is shared
then it will be cut in half if two would
be cut into the third if three cut into
a quarter and on until
and certainly you know we mentioned the
dp-10 your income tax form here in the
state of new hampshire that's certainly
another place
that could be used department of health
and human services
you know even
the
wildlife you know registering a deer i
mean there's all kinds of uses for that
information
uh in the state
further questions from the committee
you have one representative
thank you mr chairman um
the five digits versus the four digits
it sounded to me the way you described
it that we would be in violation of
federal law if we did five
but can you explain what the purpose of
that fifth one was
the fifth digit can't be used for
well would not according to this bill
would not be used for any secretary of
state purposes
okay and
the law that i was referring to did not
pass
it was at one point called hr1 and s-1
okay
but has not been passed but it is
indicative of other legislation that has
been brought forward
where
the
people who have written that legislation
down in washington have said that yeah
the last four is okay
and so reflecting that in this bill
and what we've done in the past
certainly you're going to get to
people who are going to match if you're
only using those last four digits but
remember in the election database i not
only have the last four digits i've also
got your
date and place of birth and i have other
things in there
plus your initials etc
that can be used to narrow that down and
so that when you combine those things
together
um
you know and using it as a unique
identifier
we're pretty
sure that we can get right down to you
but again i want to use it as a way for
you a citizen who goes in to vote
and either forgets your id
or
you're going in to register and you
don't have proper identification for
different things
i want to use that as a piece of
information
to help
you register to vote
without having to sign affidavits
or being able to sign the affidavit and
the inspector taking a look at it
reviewing it and then deciding that we
don't need to pursue anything further
because there is um
a record at the welfare office that you
came in and signed up for benefits or
there is uh a record of your taxes you
know
uh x number whatever uh that your
mother father's address is this and
again
if you want to make it easier for people
to vote
and don't want them to be subject to
signing all those affidavits or being
investigated because they did we need to
change something
we need to change something
this is one of those things this and the
portal are some of those things that you
can go out
and you can change
and we won't have 2 000 whatever people
signing the affidavits for not one not
two but all four of those things
identity age citizenship and domicile
right now if propriety would allow you
could walk in with nothing in your hands
and nothing on you at all
as god created you
and you could go vote
we would take your picture and we would
have you sign
and check the four boxes
anybody else from the committee
cnn thank you very much thank you now
next up
neil kirk representing himself
opposed to the bill
good afternoon once again mr chairman
and good afternoon to members of the
committee for the record i'm neil kirk i
live in where and
i'm here representing myself
representative smith good to see you
um
i'm opposed to this bill because it
requires the department to do something
which it today cannot do and that is to
demand your social security number
under current law
first-time drivers have to submit their
social security number but may request
it to be removed from the department
after they've gotten their license
under current law
the department can ask you for your
social security number but you can
decline to provide it
so right now the department for those
people who are concerned about social
security numbers privacy and all sorts
of other things
the the state through the department of
motor vehicles does not have their
social security number
this bill changes that
it gives you an option of providing your
entire social security number or only
the last five digits but one way or
another
every single person in this state when
they next register to vote and newcomers
as they register excuse me their vehicle
register i'm sorry
every time you
renew your license
first timers as well as existing license
holders you will have to provide either
the full social security number or
those five digits
now
currently
under the bill and
under current law
and i'm referring to page 1 lines
24 25 and 26.
department um
shall only make the social security
number available and remember that's
only for those people who have
voluntarily provided it
to other states for driver record
purposes to any national driver
information repository established
pursuant to federal law that could be
privately or otherwise operated it's not
necessarily federal
and
to the department of state for voter
registration purposes the last one is
new and senator gray discussed that
so
if this bill were to pass
at the very least five digits of
everyone's social security number could
go to
other states for driver record purposes
to any national driver information
repository established by the federal
government and the last four to the
secretary of state
this to me is a very major change in the
privacy protection that this legislature
has established for social security
numbers a very major change and that's
why i oppose the bill
i note that the secretary of state is
not testifying has taken no position on
this does not apparently need this
um when i checked with the secretary of
state's office some time ago
they had no position on this bill
so
while senator gray talks about the need
for this bill for a variety of election
integrity purposes as well as to make it
easier for people to vote
the authority that's really involved in
this doesn't seem to have taken a
position
the other point that i'd like to mention
is that
the dmv is currently using whatever
information they have to participate in
databases with other states and with the
national
repository
while this might make it easier for them
or make it more complete or more
accurate it is not essential it is not
necessary for them to continue business
as usual
and i hope you'll hear from them and
they will explain exactly
how this would help them and how it's
necessary and how they could live
without it
the final point i want to make
is
that i believe this would violate the
recently adopted amendment to our
constitution the privacy informational
privacy amendment
this is
article
2b
of the constitution which says
an individual's right to live free from
governmental intrusion in private or
personal information
is natural
essential
and inherent
if this state wants to get my social
security number
then this state is going to have to show
that the only way they can provide an
essential government service
is by getting that number there is no
alternative and that service is
essential those are the two criteria
that would allow the state to do that
this bill doesn't come close to meeting
that
so
i would hope this committee would as it
has in the past respect the personal
privacy of individuals
and
declare this bill and find this bill in
expedient to legislate thank you mr
chairman i'd be pleased to answer any
questions if there are any
thank you sir any questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you again thank you
sir
next up brittany shoot from the
department of motor vehicles
no position on the bill stated
good afternoon brittany shoot bureau
financial responsibility administrator
i'm here on behalf of the department of
safety to let you know what this bill
means to us and
how will impact the changes that are
proposed here
to give you a little backstory as
senator gray indicated he was looking at
how to
amend the section of the law and had
said the four digits when it was brought
to our attention we're like if we're
going to go there the five digits would
help the department of safety division
of motor vehicles better match on driver
pointers with the state to stay program
so when you move into our state there's
criteria that we match against
the network to see if that is the
correct pointer that we're pulling in
for instance you can have plenty of
steve smith and you need to make sure
that you have the right steve smith when
you're moving in
currently the way that the law is we are
still able to do our job um having the
last five would just make it more
effective for us to ensure that we're
not inadvertently canceling the wrong
driver credentials in other
jurisdictions
this is the amended version that came
out from the senate and when we had an
opportunity to read and speak with all
of you today there are a couple concerns
that we have
with the
lines 10 through
on a renewal you'll be able to opt if
you want to retain your social security
number have your social security number
removed or have your last five retained
in the system um despite the leading
lines 10 through 12 basically stating
that you're going to leave your full
social security or your last five
currently when you move into the state
you provide your social security number
and you can have the option to remove it
currently when you renew your driver's
license you can leave your social
security number on file or you can
remove it
there are certain carve outs currently
for commercial drivers and those with
real ids that we must retain your social
security number but again that is an
opt-in
situation
if this legislation would pass again
the three options of everything nothing
or the last five despite there not being
a fiscal note attached to this there is
a fiscal impact to the division to be
able to administer this and change our
database for us to be able to
accommodate these changes
and lastly the effective date
on this we would not be able to achieve
compliance and we would need to look at
when could we actually achieve
compliance with this proposed
legislation
with that i'll be happy to take any
questions
thank you any questions from the
committee
representative
thank you mr chairman
uh
thank you for taking my question
when you say that there will be some
involved with the database
is that the typical hundred thousand
dollars
that we hear about all the time
thank you for your question
if we were to look at this at an eight
week cycle that'd be about 320 hours
worth of development and we estimate
that to be roughly 128 thousand dollars
for the questions
representative tallerski
thank you thank you for taking my
question ms shoot i'm a little confused
to that that part you just directed us
to 10 to 15. the way i'm reading this is
if this goes into law you will have your
choice of either providing the full
number or the last five
correct but then the next line says
you can still check the box
to
that just directly conflicts exactly
that was the point i was trying to make
up okay i was not clear on that i wanted
to make sure that i was understanding it
because that's why i read it okay
so quick follow-up just to clarify
something
thank you
so
um i think the intent of the sponsor
was requiring the full number or the
five
and there's not an option
for no thank you i'd rather not
i do believe that was his initial intent
thanks
for the questions from the committee
representative hill
thank you um
thank you for taking my question
you're not comfortable with the 60 days
after passage is there an estimate of
how long after passage you would be able
to
thank you for your question i believe we
originally opposed january our proposed
to senator gray january the following
year
thank you
further questions from the committee
representative thompson
you said that um
this would make it easier for you
in identifying people from other states
is that correct when they apply for new
hampshire license yes thank you for your
question when individuals move in from
our state if they're participating state
to state which most of the jurisdictions
are moving there in new hampshire i
believe 36 state to join it
when the information pops up it gives
you name date of birth and social
security number and it helps you make a
better more secure match for that driver
pointer
follow up if i may follow up the um
so these 35 or six other states require
the full
social security number
thank you for your follow-up
jurisdictions have different um
requirements if they have the full
number then they post the full number
and again if they don't have the full
number then they post the last five
the last five are the american
association of motor vehicle
administrators best
practices thank you very much
representative tillerson thank you just
a quick one
um
in the section at the end of page one
where it adds the secretary of state
it's already i just want to clarify it's
already in law
that you can share
the information with law enforcement
or
the department of health and human
services only in regards to child
support enforcement and i just want to
clarify that it's only if you have the
social security numbers already in your
records correct correct we can only
share what we have available so if a
person initially provided and they opt
to remove it we can no longer use that
information and one other quick
follow-up can i ask when
i don't recall when i first moved here
and got my license providing my social
security number when did that
part of it go in i know that with the
real id
i believe that is required but when did
you start collecting social security
numbers
or
i believe we've been collecting social
security numbers i don't know the exact
date but i'll be definitely happy to
take that as an action item get back to
you just it was just thanks
representative horrigan
um
what's the uh what's the penalty for
not getting a driver's license and uh
when is is it required if you're not
actually driving in the state or
i know there's we hear a lot about the
60-day requirement but what's
what's the penalty if for some reason do
you take 61 or more days before you get
around to applying for your new driver's
license after moving here i think that's
a great question i believe there is a
statute where the first offense is 62
and the second offense is 124 dollars
is that that's for
follow-up and that's for driving with
the
license that's outdated
that would be for failing to exchange or
residency um so if you've been here for
those 60 days and you have not become a
resident as a driver as the statute
defines
okay thanks
further questions from the committee
representative sykes
thank you
um this is slightly
off topic and not particular to this
bill but anybody else from the committee
give me a chance here buddy
um
is it
is it a fact that if you
come in to get your new hampshire
driver's license you have to surrender
your driver's license from the other
jurisdiction
yes
any other questions
well seeing none i do have to point out
one thing though from your earlier
testimony
there is in fact only one steve smith
[Laughter]
shane thank you very
much uh that's the last oop that's the
last guard i have has anybody else wish
uh the wishes to speak to senate bill
yes oh
representative
i will fill it up one of the pink cards
when i'm done thank you
um
good afternoon my name is estee
representative maria perez
i represent district 23 milford
i'm here in
opposition of this bill
[Music]
i believe this bill
is
not good for our privacy
and the other reason that i'm
not supporting this bill is because it's
someone who wasn't born here
someone who is
a natural citizen
when i was
registered to vote i was sent home three
times
the first time that i went and
registered they told me that my driver's
license wasn't good enough
the second time
i was told that i need my driver's
license my
citizenship because i wasn't born here i
went and brought it
they told me that wasn't good enough i
went back home
when got my u.s citizen
my passport
so i brought three things just to prove
that i was over to and qualify
to register to vote so i don't think
saving the social security number
and the records or in the system is
going to help people like myself
i don't think they make it any easier or
it's going to make it any harder but i
don't think this is going to help
people to register and
i've been keep hearing the same thing
that is like
people
who
are illegals or people who don't
currently have residency in new
hampshire being able to just vote
because
they signed an affidavit
if that was the case
i wish that was the case when i
registered to vote
then they don't make it any easier i'm
so glad that i have
my mind set up that i want to be able to
vote at that point
but if someone who's like okay i gotta
go back to work or i have i gotta go at
taking care of my kids they give up
they don't register to vote and that's
taking away someone's right to be able
to vote so for that reason i will ask
itl this
bill you will you take any questions
okay
are there any questions
seeing
seeing then thank you very much
uh once again last call is anybody else
wishes to speak to senate bill 449
seeing none i'm going to close the
public hearing
so this is where we're at folks um first
of all a milestone our final hearing of
the term
um
we do have the two bills two second
committee bills senate bill 417 and
senate bill 442 that we do need to exec
before we leave
um
we're going to take a little bit of time
for caucusing if necessary and as a
courtesy uh i'm not taking any position
on the bill i've got to track down
senator waters because he does have an
amendment coming um that he would like
us to entertain
uh that being said
2 41
we can try three o'clock we'll shoot for
three o'clock
so thank you
okay
are we back live brad
okay thank
you do you know if representative
fenton's gone
yes okay
um
i'm going to open up the executive
session on senate bill 417 fn
chair recognizes representative smith
for a motion
thank you mr chair i move out to pass on
senate bill 417
okay um is there a second
second about representative tallersky
the bill is open for further amendment
chair recognizes representative smith
one more time thank you mr chair i move
amendment 2022
1467 s
thank you is there a second second
second by representative thompson i
already care to speak to the amendment
briefly
or not nope i just got it okay i trust
you
anybody wish to speak to the amendment
okay
representalerski thank you
um
we are looked at the amendment uh some
of us in the other room saw that it
makes the necessary changes that we
discussed this morning including to
the first lower case a bringing in the
electric distribution utilities and it
also made the change down in section
four
um changing the depart i believe it was
the department of energy previously to
the public utilities commission so i
think it took in all the concerns that
um were expressed this morning
anybody else
i do agree it just basically addressed
all the issues we had with the public
hearing this morning
uh so it's nothing else to offer on the
amendment
um
the question would be to approve
amendment 1467 s all those in favor say
aye
opposed nay
that would be unanimous so the amendment
is adopted now we're looking at the
motion on the floor 417 as out to pass
as amended
um
representative smith would you care to
speak to the bill sure
so
we've had bills about electric vehicle
programs before and the two sides are
they're incredibly expensive or they're
never going to work in new hampshire or
they're actually going to save money
committing general fund money to answer
that question has been a problem this
one though this
allows des to allocate volkswagen trust
fund money to this which was i mean when
you're looking at a budget essentially
found money
and also to seek federal funds to do
this program
i say let's just answer the question let
some municipality or area try this the
requirements of this are that they
report on how it went report on the
maintenance of the vehicle
one of the key selling points
we've been told
while the vehicles themselves are more
expensive out of the gate that the cost
of ownership is lower because they're
reduced maintenance costs no oil changes
no fuel filters none of that
so
i'm in favor of using some of the money
from that trust fund to try this
somewhere if anyone's willing they're
going to request proposals might or
might not happen for me i hope it does
and that in a few years we have data on
whether or not this is useful cheaper
and helps
thank you representative anybody else
representative sykes
yeah the other part of the program that
i think would be worth discovering is
if in fact these large batteries can
send electricity back to the grid and
save money that way as well the only way
we're going to be able to learn that is
to try a pilot program so i'm in support
of the bill
anybody else
seeing none
i'll ask the clerk to call the roll once
she's ready
uh representative smith
yes
clerk votes yes representative hill yes
representative thompson
yes
representative gorski
presented o'hare
yes
representative sykes
yes representative claudia yes
representative horrigan
yes
representative rich
yes representative tillerson
yes representative fox
yes representative stevens yes
representative
yes chairman walsh
yes
15 nothing yes 15 um committee
recommendation about to pass as amended
is adopted 15-0 i heard a motion
for consent oh ah it's an fn
yeah you're right so that'll be regular
calendar mr chair yep
uh
but it says indeterminable and
contingent on future funding
considerations so
there are cases where you can put an fn
on the consent calendar you are right
i stand corrected zero's in in the
terminal i heard a motion for consent
it's a seconded
executed by
representative o'hara without objections
consent it is seeing none okay i'll
close the executive session
on senate bill 417 event
couple of minutes to regroup
okay i'm going to open up the executive
session on senate bill 442 fn
excuse me um
chair recognizes representative gorsky
for a motion thank you mr chair i would
like to
[Music]
make a motion to otp
senate bill
442.
zero second sure second by
representative hill would care to speak
your motion
yes thank you mr chair um from listening
to testimony this morning
the department of transportation is
looking for better toll enforcement
and they talked about the process that
they go through to try to collect tolls
and one of the concerning issues we have
here is that
they mentioned last year there were
roughly 33 000 plates
that didn't pay tolls in the previous
years it was 48 000 to over 50 000 so
there's an enormous amount of revenue
that we are not collecting
as a state
even though there's a concern that they
had the dmv regarding to
[Music]
kind of tracking
families in the same household i think
this is a good bill to kind of get the
ball started so that's why i recommend
otp
thank you sir
anybody else
cnn i didn't think so you did a very
good job on that one thank you uh with
nothing else the motion on the floor is
ought to pass i'll ask the clerk to call
the role when she's ready
uh representative smith
yes clerk votes yes representative hill
yes representative thompson yes
representative gorski yes is that it
over here yes representative sykes
yes
representative
rich yes
oh i'm sorry i guess too representative
claudia yes
representative horrigan
yeah
representative toloroski
yes representative fox yes
representative stevens deaf
representative
yes and chairman walsh
yes
15 zero
all right so our committee
recommendation about to pass on senate
bill 442 is adopted um this one does
have a 250 000 expenditure so regular
calendar it goes
i'm going to close the executive session
on senate bill 442.
just give me one second i want to check
on our deadline so i can let you know of
our future plans
yeah what i'm trying to do is determine
whether or not
i think we can wait a week for the
executive sessions on the rest of these
bills and not meet next week unless
anybody finds
what's up well no unless and i'm just
looking at the calendar to make sure i
can do this
come on
the week of the deadline
which is the day i was hoping to do this
yeah well
well that's okay next tuesday
one of us
well let me ask you this there's the
reason for delaying the executive
sessions till the 26th which is the last
day for us if we still meet on tuesdays
to do it a lot can happen in two weeks
and you never know what might need to
happen differently
so
um
i i would still prefer i'll give your
opinion on it if we can still plan on
the 26th to exact the rest of these does
that sound good
it works for me
i'm not hearing anything
no issues
[Laughter]
well all right let me um
let me ask another question any of the
bills that we haven't exact today that
we heard today
rise to a level if anybody wants to
study them more as a group or we're just
going to do our own individual research
before we do executive in other words
work sessions or anything of the nature
any requests
because if we're gonna do that then we
might have to put it off for the 26th
i'm just trying to instead of me just
calling the shots here i'm just trying
to get some input from everybody on how
this works and i still like the idea of
delaying our action on the remainder of
these bills as long as possible
i'm okay with that
yeah
you know i
i was would have preferred to 19th but i
understand you're a rationale it also
means though that we don't have to come
on the same week as we have session
already true and that is
that
and that's next week
26 it is
i don't expect we'll be here long
i mean we're going to have schedules
eight bills to execute
it shouldn't be a long day and so if we
start you know our normal time in the
morning i think we're going to be home
for lunch so
if or that or i'll take you out if i
haven't no no
vacation week is a really big week for
me for work we'll talk later but i don't
see a problem
i don't see a problem
uh so back to my first question anything
we want to study further as a group or
we're just going to do our own research
i don't have any to bring up i just
figured i'd throw it out there
we're going to get some answers back
from the hospital
association right
i hope so we have ideas
and we have other questions that people
were planning on getting back to us i
can't remember the bills off the top of
my head so
that'll give us more time to yep
that's another reason okay we'll we'll
we'll seek the information we need
outside of meeting as a group so
with that thanks everybody um another
milestone done yeah and
if you have a question
uh yes i thought you were going back and
forth
yeah i probably am i'm getting tired too
and i'm just trying to accommodate
everybody i'll put it in the calendar
but it'll be the 26th
if we've only got eight bills to exec i
may not do nine maybe we could do nine
for caucus time and ten o'clock perhaps
so that actually probably makes more
sense i think eight two hours for eight
bills
is not a problem
yeah
so with